Also wenn man jetzt aktuell ist heute Mittwoch, vom nächsten Wochenende spricht, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass das das jetzt in dieser Woche kommende, also das nächste, das kommende Wochenende ist. Also dieses Wochenende, also das nächste halt, das was am nächsten an dem jetzigen Zeitpunkt dran ist.
Jetzt gerade, das sehen Sie jetzt gerade, Sir.
Alles was jetzt gerade abläuft, passiert jetzt.
Ja, und die Vergangenheit? Die ist vorbei.
Seit wann?
Seit jetzt. Wir sind jetzt im Jetzt.
Zurück in die Vergangenheit.
Na jetzt.
Jetzt?
Jetzt, das geht nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Es ist vorbei.
Seit wann?
Seit jetzt.
Wann nur das damals eigentlich jetzt?
Schon bald.
Also was jetzt kommt, das ist nicht das nächste. Genau, das kommende Wochenende ist dieses Wochenende.
Weil das kommt ja grad. Das kommt ja grad, genau.
Aber ist das nicht auch das nächste? Also was ist denn das vorige Wochenende? Das ist das jetzt, was gerade war. Ah ja und das nächste? Und nun die Konter.
Die Virtual-Maschinen-Fuzzies dürften sich auch freuen.
Alle Fuzzies freuen sich.
So haben wir einen Sendungstitel. Alle Fuzzies freuen sich.
Wir kommen noch nicht zur Hardware, oder? Nein. Was war denn noch zu High Sierra zu sagen?
Achso, eine Sache, nee, eine Sache wollte ich auch gerade sehen. Achso, High Sierra, nee, du hast jetzt gerade was anderes von der Keynote vorbeigescrollt. Das fand ich wirklich geil. Was haben sie gesagt? So, wir machen jetzt Apple Pay in der Ukraine.
In der Ukraine?
Und die Deutschen wieder so...
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht, was da eigentlich das Problem ist.
Na, die Deutsche fettern Wirtschaft.
Die Banken. Die Banken glauben, dass sie immer noch selber was mit ihrer proprietären Scheiße immer noch wieder hochkommen. Deswegen, damit die überhaupt eine Chance haben, müssen sie halt so weit blockieren wie Apple Pay. Sonst kriegen sie ihre proprietäre Scheiße nicht an Start. Für ihr E-Payment. Die blöken alle immer rum. E-Payment, E-Payment, E-Payment. Aber sie haben alle keine vernünftige Idee davon.
Quitt? Ja, aber es ist doch alles da.
Ja, aber es ist nicht von ihnen.
Ja, aber das Wichtigste ist, es fehlt der Wille.
Ja, es fehlt der Wille. Es fehlt nicht daran, dass das nicht gehen würde. Ich benutze ja meine Apple Watch andauernd.
Die sehen sich als Gatekeeper zum Geld. So wie sich die Provider als Gatekeeper zum Kunden sehen.
Ja, dann kann ja nicht einfach sein, dass Leute an der Bank vorbei irgendwelche Geldgeschäfte machen. Oder durch die Bank durch.
Machen sie ja gar nicht.
Dass die Bank einfach nur noch reiner Zahlungsdienstleister ist. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Stell dir vor, wir vier würden jetzt sagen, wir machen den Podcast jetzt ohne dich, wir brauchen dich gar nicht mehr. Du würdest ja auch nicht cool finden.
Also das würde ja nicht funktionieren, ne?
Genau, das sagt die Bank.
Falsch ansagen. Die werden erst sagen, wie sie sollen, solange ich die Flatterkohle kriege.
Ja, und den Teil haben die Banken nicht verstanden.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, dass das nur die Banken sind. Ja, es könnte auch Apple sein, die einfach auf eine bestimmte Verfügbarkeit und vor allem Partner.
Ist doch alle da. Du kannst doch jetzt schon deine Apple manchmal überall benutzen.
Weil in deinem Laden, wo du kaufst, es geht.
Ikea.
Ja.
Tankstelle.
Supermarkt. E-Dollar-Supermarkt.
Ja, Rossmann, ich weiß. Aber da gibt es ja auch noch mehr. Und keine Ahnung, wo da die Thresholds sind für Apple. I don't know. Wir wissen es alle nicht. Tatsache ist, es ist nicht da.
Solang die Apple Watch kein paar Geld ausdruckt, wird das nichts in Deutschland.
Meanwhile führen sie ja Apple Pay, wie haben sie das genannt? Ein.
Ja, aber nur, wenn man Apple Pay hat. Also ich meine, insofern ist das Thema für uns nicht spannend.
Und das wird auch erst mal wieder an europäischen vorgeschobenen oder deutschen Bankenregulierungen scheiten.
Na gut, das Thema wird in dem Moment interessant, wo es dann halt verfügbar sein wird. Ich meine, es wird ja irgendwann verfügbar sein. Hoffentlich.
Ja, aber wieder nicht in Deutschland, in Europa. An der Geschichte ist doch Flatter und Paypal schon abgeprallt, weil die sagt, du brauchst für solcherlei peer-to-peer-Finanzdienstleistungen eine Banklizenz. Vielleicht klickt sich die Apple einfach.
Nein, da brauchst du da garantie keine Banklizenz.
Also Paypal hat es ja auch hingekriegt.
Über eine luxemburgische Bank.
Nein.
Die sie sich gekauft oder gegründet haben.
Doch. Alles gar nicht.
Ach nee?
Nee.
Sondern?
Das haben sie halt auch irgendwann gemacht, weil sie halt auch Shop und Kontoführung und so weiter machen. Aber Apple macht ja gar keine Kontoführung. Apple leitet nur Käufe durch. Sie sind ein Zahlungsdienstleister. Da brauchst du keinen Status als Bank.
Ja, in dem Moment, wo du aber Peer-to-Peer-Geld machst.
Nee, auch nicht. Weil sie ja nur zwischen zwei Karten durchruten.
Jetzt komm ich dir wieder als Deutscher. Mir fällt gerade kein schöner Dialekt ein dafür. Wer haftet denn dafür? Oder wer passt denn da auf wegen Geldwäsche?
Kurze Zwischenfrage, um das besser zu klären.
Es ist einfach eine Zahlung zwischen zwei Debitcards.
Geht das direkt von deinem Konto zu meinem Konto dann, ohne dass ich zwischendurch meinen Apple Pay-Stand gucken kann? Weil dann heben die tatsächlich kein Geld auf, sondern es ist nur eine Überweisung von einem Konto auf das andere.
Aber ich hatte das auch so in der Keynote gesehen, dass du dann so deinen Apple Pay-Stand da siehst.
Weil dann heben sie schon Geld auf.
War das nicht so, dass du dann irgendwie da so siehst, wie viel Kohle hab ich denn hier gerade in meinem Apple Pay da noch?
Empfang. Ja, aber du hast kein Konto.
Und es gibt keinen Konto-Stand.
Der Konto-Stand ist dein Konto. Das ist der einzige Konto-Stand, den es gibt. Es gibt keine Balance bei Apple Pay.
Und gab es nicht auch diese Cash-Cards da? Mit denen du deinen Apple Pay aufladen kannst oder so?
Das gibt es aber so auch schon, die iTunes-Credit-Cards.
Du kannst sozusagen eine Balance haben, positiv oder negativ, auf deinem Apple Pay-Konto. Bei Apple Pay kriege ich nicht sofort eine Ab... äh, nicht Apple Pay, sondern bei meinem Apple-Account kriege ich nicht sofort eine Abbuchung, sondern irgendwann mal. Manchmal innerhalb von Minuten, manchmal erst Tage später. Also da gibt es schon negative Balances. Und dann gibt es auch positive Balances, weil dir die Leute nämlich diese Geldgutscherne, die du an jeder Drogerie kaufen kannst, einleisen kannst.
Ja, aber jetzt wo du das sagst, das war tatsächlich von irgendeiner Karte die Rede.
Cash Cards oder so. Ich muss ja nicht auch nochmal da durchscrollen, aber...
Jedenfalls fallen da den Finanzinstituten und der Regulierung dazu garantiert erstmal wieder für Jahre hinweg Gründe ein, warum das hier nicht gehen darf.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wenn sie das jetzt schon in Spanien tun, dann dürfen sie das auch in Deutschland tun. Allein weil das einfach europäische Regelungen ist.
Die machen es ja nicht in Spanien. Das ist alles US-only. Diese Person-to-Person-Geschichte ist alles US-only.
Nein, ich rede überhaupt von Apple Pay.
Na gut, Apple Pay ist ja noch ein anderes Thema. Da können sie ja wirklich sagen, ich bin ja Kreditkartenfirma und Planbob und so. Aber diese Person-to-Person-Geschichte und irgendwie so, da seh ich, da weht ein eiskalter Wind durch deren Pläne. Ein eiskalter Regulierungs- und Banken-Bahnwind.
Wüsst du nicht warum?
Also Bankenkartell kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich glaub nicht, dass Apple mit, weiß ich nicht, der Ökobank und Bank aus Luzemeyer da irgendwie als einzige Provider anfangen will, sondern die wollen natürlich die Deutsche Bank und die Sparkasse im Boot haben. Und solange sie die nicht im Boot haben, lohnt sich das für die, glaub ich.
Ich glaub, die fangen schon an mit der DKB. Also ich setze, wenn das aus Deutschland kommt, setz ich auf die DKB.
Hier, nochmal kurz, ne? Also hier, Payments will be sent from your debit card or credit card stored in Apple Wallets, in the Apple Wallet App, but any money received will go into your Apple Pay Cash Card, a virtual card that lives in Wallet. Apple is partnering with prepaid payment card company Green Dot on the virtual Apple Pay Cash Card. From there you can use the funds in the virtual card to pay others via iMessages and more. Also auf jeden Fall...
Dann haben wir Bankout gesourced.
Genau, sie haben quasi eine Karte bei einer anderen Bank, die das für sie hält. Und dann haben sie da den Balance.
Das ganze Apple Pay ist ja eh auf virtuellen Karten basierend.
Australien, Kanada, China, Frankreich, Hongkong, Irland, Italien, Japan, Neuseeland, Russland, Singapur, Spanien, Schweiz, Taiwan, UK, US.
Jetzt noch mal alles, was EU ist.
Australien macht nur beim Song Contest mit. Frankreich, Irland, Italien, Schweiz, Spanien und noch UK.
Du hast doch die Schweiz gerade vorgelesen in der ersten Runde.
Ja, aber ist nicht EU.
Ich hab ja gefragt, was jetzt nur was EU ist.
Ach so, nicht Europa, sondern EU.
Also meiner Meinung nach, sie treten nicht als Bank auf. Bank brauchst du nur, wenn du Geld hältst und das irgendwie investieren kannst und so weiter. Wenn du nur Geld durchleitest, selbst wenn es ein paar Tage dauert, dann bist du ein Zahlungsanbieter, ein Money Agent. Und dann darfst du dieses Geld nicht anlegen und so weiter. Aber du leitest es halt weiter und du unterliegst der BaFin und anderer Reunionbehörden und musst halt bestimmte Anforderungen erfüllen. Aber solche Anforderungen erfüllt Flatter. Also das sollte jetzt für Apple kein Problem sein.
In diesen Sendungen hier, von diesen 200, machen wir auch gelegentlich Voraussagen. Ich sage dir voraus, dass das Banken-Konsortium in Deutschland mit Hilfe des Bundesamts für Finanzdienstleistungen auf jeden Fall irgendwas dran findet, zu mäkeln, was die Geschichte über Monate, wenn nicht Jahre hinaus zögert.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig daran, dass die da sind, weil die lassen ja auch diese ganzen Spinner-Start-Up-Fintech-Buden machen, was sie wollen. Und die verstohen also...
Das ist aber alles Kinderkacke gegen Apple. Die haben alle Schiss vor Apple. Apple hat ganz andere Industrien aufgemischt, die mussten zusehen, wie Apple hingegangen ist, die Musikindustrie niedergezwungen hat und auch andere Medienleute und so was. Und wenn jetzt Apple plötzlich so tief in diese Finanzdingsten eingreift, dann kriegen die Panik in die Gesichter.
Find ich...
Aber ist jetzt meine Vorhersage, es wird kommen, ja, es wird kommen, aber ich sage vorher, dass es wieder tausend Reichsbedenktenträger geben werden, die im Mitte oder ohne öffentlich...
Die BaFin hat klare Regularien, die können jetzt Apple nicht den Eintritt in diesen Markt verhindern. Das Einzige, was Apple halt braucht, ist zum Start eine lange Liste von Partnern, die sozusagen mit dem Announcement allen Leuten signalisieren, alle diese Banken, wo ihr jetzt ein Konto haltet, könnt ihr in diese Wallet hinzufügen. Und das bedeutet ja, dass die quasi mit, ich weiß gar nicht genau, welches Agreement jetzt erfordern, sie müssen halt Apple quasi als Payment, haben wir mal wieder Begriff heißt, wo sie da zwischen hängen, quasi akzeptieren. Es geht ja vielmehr um, also der eigentliche Zahlungsvorgang, der ist ja klar, aber diese Autorisierung, dieses Ich fotografiere deine Kundenkarte und darüber wird dann auch automatisch diese Authentifizierung, Schlüsselausgabe gemacht mit deiner Bank, weil das ist ja sozusagen der entscheidende Prozess, der stattfinden muss. Du musst da deine EC-Karte hinlegen, Sparkasse Bielefeld, Foto machen, dann sagt er, ah hier, Sparkasse Bielefeld, tralala und dann muss es eine Kommunikation geben und die muss halt einen Key rausrücken, der dann halt in diesem Safe Space in dem iPhone gespeichert wird oder in der Watch und dann geht's los.
Die ist übrigens, wie ich jetzt gerade neulich mal feststellen durfte, extrem online, also nicht mehr so diese alte, na wir pollen mal irgendwie wat oder schicken uns mal alle drei Tage mal Bänder zu oder sowas. Ich hab ja schon seit längerem Apple Pay mit einer US-Kreditkarte und die lief neulich mal ab, da hab ich eine neue bekommen und die neue hat ein neues Design. Also früher, haben wir ja schon mal erzählt, ich hab so eine Wells Fargo-Karte und da war früher so schön in bunt und so, da war so Postkutsche drauf und jetzt ist es nur noch so eine rote Karte mit so einer stilisierten Postkutsche drauf und so. Aber egal, diese Karten musst ja auch immer freischalten. Das heißt, hab diese Karte gekriegt und da steht drauf, ich soll entweder irgendwo anrufen oder auf einer Webseite irgendwie was freischalten. Und ich hab das gemacht und innerhalb von Sekunden hat sich in meinem Apple, in meiner Wallet und auf meiner Uhr das Abbild der Karte geändert. Also ich musste nicht mal was damit machen, sondern ich hab das Telefon gar nicht in der Hand gehabt. Ich hab sozusagen nur über diese Schnittstelle von der Bank von Wells Fargo diese neue Karte freigeschaltet. Und mein Telefon macht einfach so bling, die Uhr auch so bing, ist die Karte plötzlich rot, die da dargestellt wird. Also das ist schon richtig so mit Push und hmhmhmhm.
Genau und du musst vor allem deine Uhr nicht neu pairn. Es geht alles weiter, genau. Du kannst einfach deine Karte klauen lassen, austauschen lassen und schwups gehts weiter. Ja, das mit diesem Apple Pay Cash.
Die deutschen Banken haben halt die Hose voll, weil sie genau wissen, dass es halt nicht nur über die Banken geht, sondern wie jetzt hier dieses Person to Person kommt und wahrscheinlich später noch ganz andere Dienste und die Banken dann später, wenn Apple erstmal sich mit seinem Apple Pay breit durchgesetzt hat, die Banken eigentlich gar nicht mehr gebraucht werden, vielleicht.
Ja, aber ich glaube, Banken werden immer gebraucht.
Ja, aber weniger dann.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob die sich jetzt unbedingt darum reißen, damit, also naja.
Es läuft ja, Apple löst ja nicht die Banken auf.
Ja, noch nicht?
Überhaupt nicht, ganz im Gegenteil. Sie setzen ja voll auf das System. Sie klinken sich ja voll in diesen Weg rein.
Also ich sehe da auch ehrlich gesagt, aus Bankensicht total wenig Probleme.
Für die Banken ist es ja auch sinnvoll, weil Apple ja sagt, wir übernehmen das Risiko. Wir sind uns so sicher, dass unser Ding safe ist, wir übernehmen das Risiko.
Apple sagt aber auch, ich möchte jetzt einen Teil von den Gebühren haben.
Ja, na klar, aber der Trade Deal an der Stelle ist, wir übernehmen halt auch die Verantwortung für diese ganze Transaktionsgeschichte und da gibt es halt keinen Fraud.
Aber Apple sagt doch, wir möchten auch einen Teil der Gebühren haben.
Ja, das tun aber alle Payment Provider.
Wahrscheinlich so wie ihr beiden, Apple und die Bank sitzen da auch so da und kommen sich auf den Weg.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Okay, skip, skip, skip, next.
Jetzt geht ja alle, bring mir ein Bier mit, bitte.
Da ist zweimal Coam L auf der Liste.
Ja, ich hab hier alles doppelt und dreifach.
Aber zweimal direkt hintereinander.
Wir müssen irgendwie bei, erstmal bei Software bleiben, bevor wir auf die Hard-Werbung.
Bei Sierra, also machen wir noch bei Sierra Features?
High Sierra bitte, ja?
High Sierra!
Weil was ich noch interessant fand, weil ich bin ja auch so ein Codec-Fan, es wird einen neuen Video und einen neuen Image-Codec geben. Der Video-Codec nennt sich HEVC, High Efficiency Video-Codec, denk ich mal heißt das, oder? Und Image-Codec, womit sie dann JPEG ablösen wollen, den nennen sie HEV, also eigentlich HEIF, glaube ich, also High...
Nee, das ist nicht der Codec, das ist der Container.
Was? Der... Ja, gut. Dann der Codec ist was? Auch HEVC, oder ist das auch nur der Container? Weil der Codec ist eigentlich MPEG-4, Part 10, Revision, tralala.
Also das High Efficiency Image File-Format.
Es ist klang so, als würden sie irgendwie einen Teil von dem Video-Codec missbrauchen, um damit Images zu codieren. Irgendwie so klang das.
HEIF ist quasi der neue Container. Der sagt, das hier ist ein Bild.
Ja gut, vom Container redeten wir jetzt gerade nicht.
Aber Apple. Und darin kommt der Codec der HEVC zum Einsatz für Bilder. So wie er auch für Video zum Einsatz kommt. Das heißt, es ist eine Single-Codec-Geschichte.
Und wer wissen will, was dieses HEVC ist, der kann einfach bei Pirate Bay, solange es die denn noch gibt, weil heute hat die EU gesagt, das ist nicht so toll, kann bei Pirate Bay mal so ein X265-Video runterladen. Ein freies natürlich, gibt's ja bei Pirate Bay auch freie Sachen, so ist es nicht. Und dann kann man mal sehen, wie klein die gute Qualität runterkompimiert kriegen. Und das gibt's dann demnächst mit High Sierra per Default.
Und wie klein ist es?
40 Prozent kleiner bei gleicher Qualität. Das ist auch so?
40 Prozent kleiner oder nur noch 40 Prozent so klein?
Nur noch 60 Prozent zu klein.
Spielt aber keine Rolle, weil sie eh wieder in ihrem Megapixel-Wahn sind und dauernd immer die Pixel auf der Kamera vergrößern. Das heißt im Effekt hast du nichts davon.
Naja.
Ja, ist doch gut, dass sie mit dem Codec hinterherkommen.
So bleibt es wenigstens gleich und wird nicht doppelt so groß oder so. Also es ist auf jeden Fall schon gut bemerkbar, wenn man sich mal so einen Movie anguckt. Also da kannst du locker dir so einen 2 oder 3 GB Movie in X 265 angucken und der sieht so aus, als wenn du wie früher so einen 8 oder 10 GB Movie in X 264 geguckt hättest. Also das ist schon ziemlich cooles Zeug.
Aber das ist natürlich gewagt, weil das heißt, auf allen Devices, zumindest auf den modernen Devices, werden sie das jetzt zum Einsatz bringen. Damit natürlich viel Abplatz.
Ja, sie haben da so eine Liste rausgebracht und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es für die Mac Pros ist. Aber das iPhone 7 hat noch Hardware-Support für diesen neuen Codec. Das heißt, das wird es einfach abspielen können. Das 6S, glaube ich, hatte schon keinen Hardware-Support mehr, aber in Software irgendwie. Aber ob du dann, sie haben ja gesagt, das ist ein Unterschied zwischen Dekoden und Live-Abspielen. Also das heißt, für Dekoden, das schafft das schon in Software. Und dann kannst du vielleicht da irgendwie dein Movie editieren oder so, aber live angucken kannst du es dir vielleicht nicht mehr.
Wie, du kannst deine Videos nicht mehr live angucken?
Na, wenn das in Software nicht schnell genug schafft, nicht?
Na, das kann ich mir ja nicht vorstellen, dass sie das jetzt updaten und danach kannst du deine Videos nicht mehr angucken.
Na, deine alten hast du ja noch.
Also, so wie ich das verstanden hatte, war das zumindest unter iOS so, dass sie den, also in den Bildern, die sowieso nach JPEG exportieren, wenn du sie irgendwie shares oder irgendwas anderes damit machst. Und dass sie erstmal nur in der Photolibrary in dem Format vorliegen. Also so, so klang das.
Das ist jetzt für Bilder, aber bei Bildern ist es ja auch nicht so schlimm, wenn sie das Decoding dann in Software machen, weil da gibt's kein Live, also aber für Video weiß ich nicht genau, wie da die Modalitäten sind.
Na, im Zweifelsfall machen sie es halt nur bei den Geräten, die schnell genug sind. Fertig.
Ja, also offensichtlich haben sie überhaupt diesen ganzen Codec-Bereich enorm angefasst.
Ich mach jetzt dem Opius meinen Opus.
Weil ja auch Flak und Opus tatsächlich den Weg in das System gefunden haben.
Finde ich gut, da muss man mal klatschen, weil das machen die ja nicht so oft, oder?
Ja, mit Einschränkungen. Jetzt kommt's. Es ist ein bisschen unklar, die Berichtslage. Also ich hab gelesen, dass tatsächlich Flagg-Dateien so abgespielt werden können.
Timo Hetzel hat einen Testfeed gemacht von einem seiner Zeugs, die du mit iOS 11 Beta spielen kannst, mit der eingebauten Podcast-Applikation von iOS 11, der Opus codiert ist.
Ja, aber Opus ist ja nur der Codec und der Container, in dem Opus sich normalerweise bisher befindet, ist der OK-Container. Und den kannst du nicht abspielen. Du kannst nur Opus in einem MPEG-4-Container reinpacken und darin kann er es abspielen.
Okay.
Also wenn du sagst, hier kommt eine M4A-Datei, also eine MPEG-4-Audiodatei, in einen MPEG-4-Container mit irgendwelchen Spuren, dann spielt er da auch Opus ab. Das sagt schonmal der Codec ist da. Ist vielleicht okay, kann man machen. Der Vorteil ist, man muss nicht mehr auf Honig erstmal nachrüsten, weil derzeit kann man meines Wissens da Opus noch nicht in MPEG-4 packen.
Aber der Vorteil ist, dass man Dateien nicht mehr umcodieren muss, sondern man kann die einfach nur neu einpacken. Man musste nicht transcodieren, umcontainern.
Ja, genau, also wahrscheinlich kann man das mit FF MPEG relativ easy machen.
Ja, verlustfrei. Also weil Opus ist ja mit Verlusten und Umrechnen, also wieder decoden und neu komprimieren. Das wäre ja mit extra Verlust nochmal behaftet. Und so kann man einfach das umcontainern und die Qualität bleibt gleich. Und es geht vor allem auch schneller.
Ja, also ich finde das interessant. Man hätte ja nicht unbedingt damit rechnen können, dass sie das tun, weil sie ja ansonsten immer so voll auf ihrer Impact-Welle fahren. Aber...
Vielleicht hatten sie einen neuen Praktik.
Opus macht einfach mal so viel Sinn. Kostet sie nix. Das im System zu haben, ist schon geil. Also ich meine, bevor sich das jetzt lohnt, Opus so in dieser Form als Feed anzubieten, wollen wir mal gucken.
Muss schon November werden.
Da muss doch mal wieder einer machen, sonst sind wir wieder in dieser Schleife gefangen. Du sagst jetzt, naja, was soll ich ein Feed anbieten? Gibt ja noch keine Devices dafür.
Nein.
Und die Device-Hersteller sagen, ja, was soll ich Devices dafür anbieten? Hätte ja noch keiner ein Feed dafür.
Und einer muss das mal durchbrechen.
Ja, aber ich sag dir mal, was das eigentliche Problem ist. Das eigentliche Problem ist nicht so sehr der Codec. Der ist geil. Das Problem ist der Container. Und MPEG-4 ist einfach ein Schmerz im Arsch. Ein Schmerz im Arsch. Und der Schmerz kommt vor allem daher, dass halt so Metadatensachen da einfach als einzelne Spuren sind. Es gibt irgendwie immer noch keinen Standard für so was Simples wie Kapitelmarken. Es gibt so ein Best Practice, den Apple irgendwie erkennt und den sie in ihrem Betriebssystem drin haben. Und wenn es dir gelingt, eine Datei zu erzeugen, wo diese Kapitelmarken so sind, wie das Betriebssystem sie akzeptiert, dann hast du Glück, dann bereitet das...
Den sie aber auch schon geändert haben, den Best Practice.
Ja, den sie geändert haben mindestens zweimal und den sie mittlerweile so weit geändert haben, dass wenn du so eine Datei bereitstellst mit Kapitelmarken, so wie das iPhone sie heute haben möchte, du einen alten iPod-Shuffle damit einfach direkt ins Jenseits schickst. Und versuchst abzuspringen.
Sehr gut.
Genau, sehr gut. Und jetzt ist ja MP3 frei. Seit diesem Jahr, seit einem Monat ist MP3 komplett aller Lizenzgebühren frei und wird sich einfach weiter als das Universal-Audio-Format durchsetzen. Und dieses vergleichsweise einfache Tagging in MP3-Containern, das ist so einfach und so flexibel und da funktioniert irgendwie alles und da ist irgendwie alles definiert und da gibt es Kapitelmarken und Bilder und Pipapo und du kannst es da auch viel flexibler reintun. Ja, we will never die.
It's free. Was würdest du dir denn wünschen? Du sagst, Opus lebt auch im Org, kann Org das besser? Würdest du jetzt sagen, Apple macht doch mal Org, weil euer MP3-Format riecht auch aus dem Mund?
Org ist auch ein Auliger-Container. Ich hab eigentlich nichts gegen MP4, aber es ist halt einfach unterspezifiziert. Und du hast halt so Probleme, dass du eben mal nicht alles an den Anfang einer Datei packen kannst. Also Kapitel tauchen halt in einer MP4-Datei immer genau an der Stelle in der Datei auf, wo das Kapitel auch anfängt. Und dann steht dabei, wie das Kapitel heißt. Aber mal eben die Datei kurz mal so zu pasen und mal zu schauen, was sind die Kapitel-Informationen da drin ist, ist schon ein richtiger Task. Weil dann musst du so einmal durch die ganze Datei durchskippen, was natürlich so im Internet mit Laden und HTTP eine Weile dauern kann. Während du halt bei MP3 das einfach an Anfang packen kannst.
Also du sagst, eigentlich bräuchte es einen neuen Container für neue Formate, der nicht so riecht. Ah, einen neuen Container.
Das bräuchte mal etwas sinnhaftere Podcasting-kompatible Metadatenspezifikationen für diesen MPEG-4-Container. Und vor allem mal Sample-Code, Sample-Code, Sample-Code von Apple, dass man Leute sich das einfach angucken kann, implementieren können, macht das Open Source, haut das einfach alles raus, was sitzt ihr auf diesem Scheiß? Was soll das? Kapitel machen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es direkt wieder an Apple liegt, sondern das hängt auch wieder an welchen Lizenzen, die sie dafür haben, an welchen Patenten oder so.
Das liegt nur an Apple.
Und an deren Torfnasigkeit? Ja, oder sind da überkandierte Lawyer am Berg? Oder was, wie?
Was jetzt konkret der Grund ist, darüber kann ich nur spekulieren. Ich vermute mal, das hat irgendwie so was mit naja, wir wollen das ja später vielleicht nochmal anders machen.
Zu tun.
Ich finde, wir starten mal wieder so eine Podlauf auf Crowdfunding-Geschichten, schickt dich nächstes Jahr zur WWDC, da gehst du dann einfach mal hin zu diesem Apple-Developer, der genau diese Scheiße da in der Hand hat und wäscht den Mann den Kopf.
Ja, wenn es da einen gibt.
Die haben das jetzt extra nach San Jose verlegt, weil sie gesagt haben, wir haben jetzt Tausende von ihren Freggeln, die sie dahin geschickt haben, von ihren Original-Apple-Mitarbeitern da. Dann schicken wir, machen wir Podlauf, Dingsen schickt dich nach Kalifornien. Ach, mit seinem Pass, du kommst noch besser durch als wir.
Scheiß auf Britannien, Idioten.
May Theresa be with you.
Das spricht mich nicht auf Britannien an.
Jetzt fällt mir gerade nochmal die Eröffnung von Trainsporting ein, so mit den Schotten und den Briten.
Jaja, und den Englern dann.
Ja genau, den, das war's.
Lass uns ausnahmsweise mal ein bisschen in der Themengeschichte sein, wo wir das jetzt gerade so auf Podcasting gehoben haben. Es gab ja auch neue, es gibt so ein 30, ich mach mal dein Mikrofon aus, Clemens. Also es gab ein Talk zu Podcasting. Zehn Jahre nachdem sie da mal irgendwie mit angefangen haben, haben sie das erste Mal eine signifikante Änderung zu Podcastfeeds gemacht. Das laufen alle raus. Wo ist überhaupt mein Bier? Ach, hier.
Und alle so yeah.
Wo ist mein Flaschenöffner?
Der war nicht bestellt. Du wolltest nur ein Bier.
Wo ist meine Sprechhilfe? Wo ist mein mentaler Beistand? Dankeschön. Noch jemand da, den das interessiert? Ich red einfach mit den Hörern. Ich kann nicht alleine Podcast machen. Ich komme auf den Punkt. Also es gibt ja schon seit Jahr und Tag diese iTunes Feed Extensions. Und die sind eigentlich eine dolle Sache. Hätten sie mich gefragt, ich hätte da noch ein paar Sachen anders gemacht, aber mich fragt ja keiner.
Noch nicht.
Und im Prinzip muss man sagen, die iTunes Feed Extensions haben so diese ganzen Podcasting-Geschichte zum richtigen Zeitpunkt belebt und das ist so der de facto Extensionsatz eigentlich für Podcasting. Obwohl es halt sich hierbei um eine Spezifikation für iTunes handelt. Deswegen heißt ja auch der Präfix dafür iTunes Doppelpunkt. Soweit so okay. In den letzten Jahren haben sie eigentlich nichts anderes gemacht als ein Lieblingsfelder so ein bisschen unter den Tisch fallen zu lassen. Eins haben sie mal weggelassen, das ist iTunes Keywords. Da konnte sie noch so Tags angeben. Das haben sie dann eingesehen, dass das irgendwie nichts ist. Das haben sie dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr dokumentiert. Das braucht man gar nicht mehr zu benutzen. Das ist irgendwie auch schon immer Quatsch gewesen. Tags und so, das funktioniert, Tags funktionieren nicht. Also Tags funktionieren für einen selbst, aber Tags funktionieren nicht für alle. Und außerdem haben sie ja diese schöne Trinität, Titel, Untertitel und Summary definiert, die wir zum Beispiel bei Potlaffextensive nutzen. Und jetzt gibt es neue Extensions. Dann haben sie so einen Talk gemacht und haben gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt auch Seasons. Und wir definieren jetzt auch mal die Episodennummer als solche. Und gehen nicht nur davon aus, dass das irgendwie im Titel mit drin steht. Tolle Sache. Haben wir bei Potlaffe auch schon mal probiert, konnten uns aber nicht so richtig auf die Details einigen. Seasons haben wir allerdings drin. Das heißt, wir werden das relativ einfach implementieren können. Aber ganz mal unabhängig jetzt von Potlaffe, haben sie jetzt dieses Summary-Fail zu einem Untertitelfail degradiert. Und das finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen weird. Also das, was man derzeit so als umfangreiche Beschreibung mit bis zu 4.000 Zeichen definiert hat, die letzten 13 Jahre oder 10 Jahre, ist jetzt auf einmal ein Sachs in einem Satzfeld. Also sie machen eine semantische Umdefinition eines seit langer, langer Zeit existierenden Dings, weil sie das jetzt in ihrer Podcast-App und in iTunes irgendwie anders spezifizieren wollen oder wo sie wohl glauben und festgestellt haben, dass die Leute das sowieso nicht richtig verstehen und nicht richtig benutzen. Was durchaus sein kann. Das hätte man auch anders lösen können, Apple. Echt. Trotz alledem, die neuen Änderungen sind an sich ganz sinnvoll und sie haben auch nochmal ein paar Sachen bekräftig, die wichtig sind. Sowas wie ein Podcast-Feed muss für jede Episode so eine richtige Guide enthalten und die sollte sich nicht ändern und so. Dann probieren sie noch so Sachen, wie du kannst sagen, was deine Episode ist. Ist das eine richtige Episode? Oder ist das nur ein Trailer? Also machst du nur so ein und demnächst kommt Freak Show 200. Oder ist das so Bonuskram? Sowas weiß ich. Und jetzt hier noch das Gequatsche nach der Sendung nochmal als einzelne Aufnahme. Ja, weiß nicht so ganz genau, was ich davon halten soll. Vermute, sie werden sich da in ihrer Podcast-App, die habe ich mir jetzt noch nicht angeschaut, die neue Version, irgendwas einfallen lassen, wie sie das halt visualisieren. Und vielleicht macht diese Unterscheidung auch Sinn. Geht dann ja auch so in Richtung Bonus-Content. Es gibt allerdings nichts, was in irgendeiner Form so Paywalls oder sowas ermöglichen würde. Also, dass man jetzt so bezahlte Feeds macht, dafür ist leider überhaupt nichts hinzugefügt worden. Es geht nach wie vor alles davon aus, dass es offen ist. Und dann haben sie noch, und das ist eine sehr sinnvolle Änderung, so eine Art Podcast-Typ eingeführt, wo sie generell es ermöglichen zu unterscheiden zwischen einem normalen Podcast, sogenannten Episodic-Podcast. Also, so wie hier. Neue Folge kommt raus. Das ist das erste, was du hören willst. Beziehungsweise, wenn du heute Freak Show abonnierst, diese Sendung ist draußen, dann ist die Freak Show 200 die erste, die du siehst. Dann kommt die 199, 198 etc. Wenn du allerdings den Podcast als ein Serial deklarierst, dann kriegst du immer die erste Folge der aktuellen Season. Also Beispiel Freak Show weitergespielt. Wir haben ja hier eigentlich keine Seasons. Wir haben eigentlich einzigen Seasons, die wir haben, das hieß mal Mobamex, heißt Freak Show.
Na, wir haben eine Sommerpause. Du könntest eine Season 17, 18 machen.
Ja, könnte ich halt machen, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass die Sendungen aufeinander aufbauen. Das geht halt jetzt eher um sowas wie...
Stimmt.
Du fängst halt, ja, ok, könnte man auch so machen. Oder wenn du einen Fußballpodcast hast, kannst du tatsächlich auch wirklich eine Fußballsaison als Begrenzung nehmen. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Podcast-Post drin.
Roddy hat doch ein Beta drauf auf seinem Ding. Hast du da auch die aktuelle Podcast ab?
Ja, die müsste auch dabei sein.
Ich hab da bloß noch nicht drauf geschaut. Dann kann man ja da mal schauen.
Lass mich kurz noch zu Ende bringen. Also du hast quasi die Möglichkeit, wenn du jetzt so einen Serial-Podcast hast, dann heißt das, lad die erste zuerst, weil die halt aufeinander aufbaut, weil du eine Geschichte erzählst. Serial, ja ok, passt ja auch schon zu dem passenden Podcast Serial und das ist sinnvoll. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine Geschichte erzählen willst, so ein dokumentarisches Ding oder so ein Education-Podcast, der so, was weiß ich hier, ich erklär dir immer Philosophie und ich fang bei A an, so. Dann willst du den abonnieren und du willst den ersten Podcast als erstes haben. Das ist also sinnvoll und wenn du Seasons hast und das Ding ist Serial, dann kriegst du halt die erste Folge der Season. Macht auch Sinn. Leider, leider, leider immer noch keine Paged Feeds, immer noch kein Konzept dafür, wie man viele Sendungen mit vielen Show-Notes in einem Feed halten kann, ohne dass dieser Feed explodiert. Einschließlich iTunes. Ich versuch schon immer irgendwie da Leuten...
Aber das war das andere, das war das andere da hinzuschreiben oder die Leute persönlich an den Wickel zu kriegen. Merkst du auch mit ITF und so. Das ist echt normal.
Das ist aber auch ein feurer Spaß dahin zu fliegen.
Deswegen sag ich ja, wer kraut von...
Zeigt aber immer noch irgendwie... Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das Show Note nennen kann, aber... Ja, die Podcast Ab zeigt immer noch irgendwie Show Notes an. Also nicht nur...
Natürlich zeigt sie Show Notes an.
Nicht nur Summaries, das ist doch das, was du meinst.
Nein, es gibt ein Feld, das heißt iTunes Summary. Das war bisher definiert als, hier hast du bis zu 4.000 Zeichen Platz, um eine Summary zu machen. Und jetzt heißt es Single Sentence, der sicherlich nicht aus 4.000 Zeichen bestehen sollte.
Das ist aber nur eine semantische Neudefinition. Ja, aber es ist... Sie sind immer noch da.
Ja, aber das Alberne ist, sie hatten das schon, und das war der Subtitle. iTunes Doppelpunkt Subtitle war genau so definiert. In einem Satz zusammenfassend. Und genau so habe ich das immer benutzt. Nur jetzt wechseln sie das auf Summary, weil keiner den Subtitle setzt, alle schreiben es in die Summary. Da steht meistens relativ wenig drin, weil den Leuten nichts einfällt, wie sie irgendwas zusammenfassen sollen. Sodass sie jetzt so quasi realitätsbasiert sagen, naja, dann nehmen wir doch Summary und verwenden es so wie Subtitle. Und Subtitle ist zwar auch noch da, aber ist nicht anders definiert. Und die Summary ist nicht mehr da. Und was mach ich jetzt mit meinem Feed, wo ich lange Summaries drin habe? Soll ich die dann ändern? Das ist doch irgendwie alles gaga. Also das halte ich für wirklich ein total miesen Move und das ist einfach nicht schön. Die Idee mit Seasons und mit Episoden-Nummern finde ich gut. Auch wenn sie sagen, dass eine Episoden-Nummer bei 1 anfangen muss. Warum auch immer.
Null wäre viel logischer, ne?
Ja. Also an der Stelle, schöner Bezug zur letzten Sendung.
Was ist mit der 1 angekommen?
Ich meine, ich mach halt Null-Nummern und die Null-Nummer ist halt Nummer Null. Also so. Könnte man jetzt als Trailer setzen. Dann sagen sie aber auch nichts dazu, ob die Episoden-Nummer jetzt für normale Episoden gilt oder gilt das dann auch für den Trailer oder auch für den Bonus-Track. Also da wird man noch so einiges herausfinden müssen. Und das sind alles Probleme, die wahrscheinlich niemanden interessieren, außer Leuten, die Podcast-Software schreiben. Von daher...
Na, ein Großteil unserer Hörer besteht ja da.
Ja, schön wär's.
Großteil unserer Hörer schreibt Podcast-Software.
Ein größerer Teil unserer Hörer könnte mal Podcast-Software schreiben. Leute, falls ihr in eurer Freizeit...
Das muss so sein, wir passen ja unseren Content, unseren Hörern an.
Leute, wenn ihr in eurer Freizeit noch ein bisschen Luft habt und so Potluff hires, für Null Euro. Okay, genug zu Podcasting.
Alle wieder Kopfhörer auf.
So, wollen wir über IOS reden oder über Hardware? Ich find ja IOS nicht so spannend, aber Roddy hat sich das bestimmt angeguckt.
Es gibt diversen Kram unter IOS, der... Naja, man kann... Also ich muss nicht über ARKit oder Core ML reden, da hab ich auch keinen Plan zu... Naja, dieses Augmented Reality... Das wird nicht besser, ne?
Hast du Spaß an der NFC für deine Arbeit oder ist das da irgendwie interessant, spannend?
Haben sie das jetzt so ein bisschen aufgemacht im Gegensatz zu früher, oder was ist da genau der Stand?
Genau, das hab ich dahin geschrieben, weil ich das spannend fand, dass es tatsächlich für iPhone 7 und 7 Plus jetzt eine API gibt, um NFC zu machen.
Aber...
Ich hab mir die nicht näher angeguckt.
Red Only.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, was die tut.
Aber warum nur das 7er-iPhone das, also...
Die macht nicht viel. Also das ist im Wesentlichen nichts anderes, als du kannst sagen, ich will jetzt was lesen, dann gibt's dann so ein Standard-UI dafür und er liest halt irgendwie alle fünf verschiedenen NFC-Typen, die so auf dem Markt sind und zeigt dir die Metadaten an und fertig. Mehr ist das nicht.
Der konnte da auch schon NFC lesen, der kann auch Apple Pay.
Ich vermute, dass das was mit der Sicherheitsarchitektur zu tun hat, die sie da vielleicht überarbeitet haben.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Reader, der eine ist secure und der andere ist jetzt für...
Keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, da sind sie wirklich versessen da drauf, dieses Apple Pay-Ding auf jeder erdenklichen Ebene so wasserdicht zu machen.
Vielleicht haben sie da einen anderen Chip, haben sie keinen Treiber für... Irgendwie so ein Scheiß wird das sein. Was weiß ich.
Ich verstehe die andere Frage, weil das ist ein bisschen NFC-ähnlich. Was ist jetzt, dass die Kamera jetzt QR-Code scannen kann? Ist das so ein Default jetzt immer oder wie läuft das?
Nein, das ist ein...
Also das einerseits ein Core ML, also dieses Maschinen-Learning-Zeug, da ist das irgendwie drin. Richtig verstanden habe ich es nicht.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Du kannst halt irgendwie relativ viel Grafikerkennungszeug machen und da gehört halt auch QR-Code und Barcode dazu.
Genau, also wir haben das jetzt alles eingebaut, aber sie haben dieses generelle, wir erkennen jetzt Dinge in Video oder in anderen Daten-Phasienes unter Verwendung unserer Maschinen-Learning-Algorithmen.
Was ja auf der anderen Seite Sinn macht. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Ups ich drauf habe, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise was mit QR-Codes zu tun haben und jeder von denen schleppt seine eigene Leiberäder für mit. Genau, und nicht nur das.
Sie haben z.B. auch standardmäßig einen Dokumentenerkenner. Also so dieses so...
Ah, nicht geschafft zu drücken.
Ja, den hab ich auch schon ausprobiert und der funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Du legst halt einen Zettel auf den Tisch und fotografierst ihn aus einem Winkel und dann erkennt er, wo der Zettel ist und entzerrt ihn dir so hin, dass du hinterher halt einen schönen rechteckig entzerrten.
Das liegt immer schon von meiner Scanner ab von 1874. Ja, jedes Scanner ab und ihr clone.
Ja, aber jetzt ist es halt ein Feature des OS.
Slow clap.
Nee, ich find das super.
Ja, ich auch, aber es ist trotzdem so ein Slow clap.
So ein Single clap.
Es gibt da einen Spin, weil...
Oh, jetzt kommts.
Wie sie das implementiert haben, also es gibt dieses Core ML. Also es ist quasi Ihr Maschinen-Learning-Kern-Framework. Das ist jetzt Teil von IOS und vom Microsoft, von Micros. Und das kommt unter anderem mit so einem Dateiformat.ml. Irgendwas, also sie haben so ein Dateiformat definiert, wie du trainierte, wie nennt man denn diese Dinger, also trainierte Machine Learning, sag ich jetzt mal ganz blöd.
Machines?
Ja, sowas, also so erlerntes aus entsprechenden Machine Learning-Systemen. Es gibt da ja verschiedene da draus. Es gibt das Ding von Google, dann gibt es diverse, Kaffee, Open Source.
Und sie haben das jetzt mal in den Standard.
Und die haben alle sehr unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen, wie du die Daten da reinfütterst, wie du das lernen machst und so weiter. Das ist aber vollkommen unabhängig von dem, was Apple macht. Apple sagt nur, es gibt ein definiertes Format, wie du diese Output, wie du den Output dieser Trainierer-Systeme in eine Datei packst und dann kannst du die in unsere Hardware reinladen. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendeinen Trainings-Setup hast für Machine Learning, was halt irgendwas lernt, was was ich lerne, wie Katzen in Videos zu erkennen oder lernt, popelnde Leute auf Demonstration zu erkennen oder was auch immer, Autofahren, Pipapo, dann kannst du diese Lerndateien quasi so paketieren, dass du sie in iOS 11 einfach zum Einsatz bringen kannst. Das heißt, es schafft jetzt quasi auch so einen Zuführungsmarkt. Du kannst diese Dienstleistung auch in Anspruch nehmen. Du könntest jetzt als App-Programmierer sagen, ich brauch diese Erkennungsleistung, gehe zu Leuten, die davon was verstehen und lass mir das in diesem Format anliefern, zahl dafür, lade die rein und kann die in meiner App auf einem Datenstrom aktivieren. Ich kann halt Kamera anschalten und sagen, erkenne mir das.
Das heißt, ich kann demnächst so inner-purchasemäßig alle popelnen Leute kaufen und dann mit meiner Kamera drauf halten und dann Ding-Ding werden die so getaggt.
Ja, ich dachte jetzt richtig als Dienstleistung für ein Programmierstudio, die das dann halt so anliefern und dann hast du das in deinem Programm. Das kann man natürlich auch etwas popularisierter sehen. Inner-purchasemäßig, meinetwegen kann auch sein, aber darum geht es ja nicht. Es geht darum, es gibt ein Framework, in dem das alles abstrahiert ist und womit es dann eben auch automatisch sich beschleunigen lässt, mit der Hardware, die Apple halt hat, also sprich in den GPUs. Und das ist schon ganz schön fancy, Schmenzi. Und viele Sachen, die sie halt gezeigt haben und viele Sachen, die sie jetzt halt hinzugefügt haben, wo man sagt, aber das haben die anderen ja schon lange. Ja, haben sie teilweise, aber es ist halt mal ganz anders implementiert worden. Und wird man dann sehen, potenziell besser, schneller. I don't know. Also und da fällt dann halt so was wie QR-Code erkennen mal so eben bei raus. Also das ist dann oder halt auch Dokumentenerkennung, weil sie das halt dieses Kamera-Erkennzettel und Inzert, das haben sie halt irgendwie trainiert. Und so werden sie da alles Mögliche durchjagen. Und von daher diese ganze Erkennung und auch dieses neue AR-Kit, dieses Augmented Reality Kit basiert letzten Endes auch auf diesem ganzen Core-ML-Kram. Das heißt, wenn du deine Kamera halt auf irgendeinem Environment hältst, und sie haben mir diese Demo da gezeigt, wo sie dann halt so einen Tisch erkennen, wobei ich das so ein bisschen verdächtig fand, dass es immer so gemaserte Tische waren, immer so Tische mit so extrem viel Strukturen. Da hätten wir also mal ein weißer Küchentisch. Das hätte mich überzeugt.
Aber sie stehen da auf einer Bühne noch mal mit spezieller Beleuchtung und so weiter. Also das kann man ihnen jetzt nicht verdenken.
Das hätte mich richtig umgehauen. So dachte ich mir so, okay, Tisch mit Maserung.
Auch trotzdem fand ich das Spiel, was er da gezeigt hat, wo irgendwie dann dieser Piepel da vom Tisch gefallen ist und so, das fand ich schon ganz nett.
Zweifelsohne, ich meine, die Frage ist immer, wofür kann man das benutzen?
Das werden wir dann sehen.
Was ist die wirkliche Anwendung? Also für Spiele, für Kinderspiele kann ich mir das schon sehr lustig vorstellen und für so Entertainment-Games, aber wir werden sicherlich auf der Basis überhaupt erst jetzt neue Anwendungen sehen.
Auch so eine interaktive iFixit-Anleitung fände ich auch ganz schick. Also ich hab neulich mein Mac Mini auseinandergebaut und erst als das Alugehäuse komplett leer war, konnte ich dann anfangen, die SSD einzubauen.
Ich meine, es gibt ja schon Anwendungen, die schon seit einiger Zeit draußen sind, die so in Gänsefüßchen AR machen. Also eine ist ja dieses komische Flight-Rader-Ding, was es schon ewig gibt, wo du halt dein Telefon an den Himmel hältst und dann... Ja, war zu unmittelmäßig gut funktioniert. Die andere Anwendung, die ich häufiger benutze, also ein Gegenden mit echt obskuren Sprachen.
Das ist ja nur die Messung der Richtung.
Deswegen sag ich ja, aber das sind Anwendungen, die in die Richtung gehen, die jetzt von einem solchen Framework vielleicht profitieren würden, weil die Erkennung besser ist. Sternenhimmelgeschichten. Oder was ich schon häufiger benutze, ist halt diesen Google Translator in diesem Live-Modus, wo du halt wirklich durch die Kamera durchguckst und die Software replacest dir überall dort, wo halt irgendwie Japanisch standet, halt eben in übersetzter Form. Sowas ist geil. Und das funktioniert zwar schon ganz gut, aber das wäre natürlich noch mit ein bisschen mehr Umf drum herum, also mit so einem AR-Framework könnte das durchaus noch sexier werden.
Da fällt mir der Film Sie leben ein, wo die diese Brillen finden, wo dann immer anstatt der Werbung steht dann mal da Obey oder Buy Me oder irgendwie so Sachen.
Oder hatten sie es nicht auch erwähnt, dass sie auch so Schilder erkennen und übersetzen? Sie machen ja jetzt auch übersetzen. Von Englisch nach acht anderen Sprachen einschließlich Deutsch, glaube ich. Und auch das angeblich auf Basis eines kompletten neuen Trainings. Das weiß ich nicht genau. Sie haben sich auch neue, sie haben sich mit ihrem Machine Learning ja auch einen Sprachgenerator jetzt zusammengeklickt. Das heißt Siri ist nicht mehr eine zusammengestückelte Originalstimme, sondern Siri ist jetzt eine Maschinengenerierte Stimme. Und alles, was da rauskommt, ist komplett auf Basis von Machine Learning generierte Phonembildung. Das heißt, die Stimme, die da jetzt zu dir spricht, ist so eine...
Durchschnittsstimme aus mehreren Rechern.
Das erste Mal eine echte computergenerierte Stimme, die mit Nuancen daherkommt und so weiter und verschiedene Dinge. Dann sagt dreimal das Wort selber so und there's milk, there's milk and there's milk. Das ist auf jeden Fall mega advanced und man merkt, dass sie da richtig on fire sind und dass sie da jetzt richtig viel mitmachen wollen.
Ja, aber was interessant ist, ist halt Grundlagentechnik. Das ist Grundlagentechnik, wo jetzt erst mal viele Leute mit dem Schulteranzug sagen, ja, hab ich noch keine Anwendung für oder ist ja bäh, Beta und so weiter und so fort. Aber das finde ich wiederum gut, dass so eine Firma mit so einer Marktmacht solche Grundlagentechnik herstellt und die dann auch entsprechend verbreitet über ihre Verbreitungskanäle, die sie haben mit ihrer Marktmacht, damit es so weit auch mal aus dem Kniff kommt.
Was ich ganz positiv finde, ist, dass sie halt eine API und eine, sagen wir schon, eine relativ weit gediehene Lösung bringen und nicht irgendwie wie Google dieses TensorFlow. Ich hab mir das ja auch mal runtergeladen. Das ist halt ein Haufen C++ und Python-Zeug, was du irgendwie, du packst das Ding aus und denkst dir so, ja und jetzt? Soll ich jetzt irgendwie aus einzelnen Mehlkrümeln mein Brötchen zusammenkleben oder was? Was ist es so?
Genau, und jetzt machst du so drei Calls, schaltest die Kamera ein, lädst da dein Machine Learning-Ding und dann kriegst du schon Events, was in deinem Bild irgendwie angeblich ist.
Das heißt, die Idee, die Pavel da, die er uns gezeigt hat mit seinem Programm, ist?
Genau, das, was Pavel da von Hand gemacht hat. Pavel war ja ja neulich zu Gast, aber ich weiß nicht, haben wir denn überhaupt darüber geredet, über seine Exploration von Machine Learning?
Der hat uns ja die App gezeigt. Mit irgendwie 4.000 oder 2.000 Objekten, die er da angelernt hatte.
Genau, also er hat quasi das Lernen auch selber gemacht. Also ich glaube, das hat er mit Kaffee gemacht, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Und er könnte im Prinzip jetzt seine Learnings, die er da gemacht hat, auch in dieses Core ML, diese Beschreibungssprache überführen, in iOS reinladen und hätte das dann quasi so auf System-Ebene. Und könnte das halt in einer App benutzen, die sonst überhaupt nichts davon weiß, die einfach nur da dieses API benutzt. Also, ja, mal schauen. Ich glaube, das ist so eine Technologie, das wird jetzt nur eine Weile dauern, bis wir da so richtig coole Sachen sehen, aber vielleicht hat auch relativ bald jemand da eine geile Idee. Also gerade so dieses, das gab es ja vor einigen Jahren schon mal, so eine App, die so, du hältst sie in Japan an ein Schild und das sagt dir, was auf dem Schild steht. Bloß wenn man da halt sowohl auch bei schlechtem Wetter, aus größerer Distanz, mit kriegliger Schrift das lesen kann und das Learning auch semantisch so gut ist, dass es den Kontext soweit erahnen oder zumindest sich annähern kann, dass es dir auch eine Erklärung gibt, die in dem Moment auch stimmt. Wir wissen, Schilder können sehr doppeldeutig sein. Dann wäre, glaube ich, eine Menge gewonnen.
Selbst auf Deutsch. Oder gerade auf Deutsch.
Genau, und das dann auch noch auf Deutsch. Ja, so viel zu diesem Maschinen-Learning-Kram. Mehr kann man da derzeit noch nicht zu sagen.
Also dieses iPad-Control Center, das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool. Ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, weil es erstmal komisch aussieht mit diesen ganzen Quadraten.
Sieht komisch aus, ist aber so.
Ist aber so. Ist aber ganz cool.
Sag doch erstmal was überhaupt zu iPad.
Was soll ich da überhaupt zu sagen? Hat auch 11 Beta.
Ja gut, aber die eigentliche News ist, iOS 11 ist das erste iOS, was nennenswerte Änderungen auf dem iPad mit sich bringt und nur auf dem iPad mit sich bringt.
Richtig?
Das könnte man so sagen, ja. Für iPhone ist da nicht viel drin gewesen.
Nee, diese ganze Drag-and-Drop-Geschichte und mit bis zu vier Programmen.
Funktioniert auf dem iPhone freischaltend.
Funktioniert auf dem iPhone theoretisch auch, ja.
Aber du hast halt nicht dieses, du kannst vier Apps gleichzeitig auf den Screen bringen.
Das ist am iPhone nicht.
Ja, vier.
Zwei. Vier. Seit wann denn vier?
Gestern, morgen, nächste.
Und du hast ja auch so Overlays und so weiter. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur wie bisher, zwei mit Side-by-Side, sondern du kannst die dann übereinander legen und so. Und ja, das heißt, dass sie jetzt...
Du bist dann zu alt davon.
Und dieses ganze Drag-and-Drop ist wohl auch ziemlich sophisticated. Ich hab jetzt nicht so viel Erfahrung mit solchen Systemen.
Na ja, so auf den ersten Blick ist es gleich im Drag-and-Drop wie in Mac OS. Also zumindest von der Technologie dahinter.
Das ist Multitouch.
Ja, schon, aber die API, die dahinter steckt, ist genauso painful. Ja, du musst zu allen Objekten, die eine Drag-Source sein können, musst du die Drag-Source implementieren und zu allen Objekten, die eine Drag-Destination sein können, musst du eine Drag-Destination implementieren. Und das ist alles, es testet sich unheimlich schlecht. Also, sie haben zwar gesagt, ja, hier zwei Zeilen Code und dann ist alles super, aber ganz ehrlich, ja. Und du hast bei iOS jetzt, anders als bei macOS, hast du sogar noch mehr da drin. Nämlich du hast eine Lift-Animation und eine Drop-Animation. Die gibt es bei macOS nicht. Nur bei iOS kannst du halt draufdrücken und dann wuppt das Ding hoch. Und die kannst du ja dann auch noch irgendwie selber implementieren, wenn dir danach ist, Animationen zu implementieren. Also, ich würde, ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich glaube, dass so ein paar low-hanging fruits werden, die die Entwickler relativ schnell implementieren. Aber jetzt davon auszugehen, dass auf die Schnelle alles, was irgendwie iPad ist, man plötzlich von überall nach überall hin drag and dropen kann, das halte ich jetzt mal die Hoffnung für ein bisschen übertrieben. Dazu ist es dann, glaube ich, doch ein bisschen zu komplex. Aber ja, warum nicht?
Hier wird gerade gesagt, drag und drop läuft über APFS-Snapshots wegen der Sicherheit.
Du kannst ja normalerweise nicht in die Dateibereiche von anderen Leuten reingreifen als AUS ab.
Wenn du eine Datei dragst und dropsst, dann dragst du ja nicht die Datei, sondern du dragst eine Filesystem Promise, wie es so schön heißt. Also im Prinzip nur den Link auf die Datei. Und ich nehme mal an, dass sie über APFS irgendwie die Datei dann in den anderen Containerreihen einblenden, wahrscheinlich über irgendeinen Clone oder sonst irgendwas. Irgendwas haben sie da auch erzählt zum Thema Sicherheit. Das habe ich nicht auf Anhieb verstanden.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob es Snapshots waren oder ob es nur irgendwie so ein Mounting...
Sind wahrscheinlich Clones.
So Virtual Mounts. Aber das sind ja auch Snapshots letzten Endes. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist das securitymäßig auch ziemlich umfangreich.
Also das eine, was du natürlich willst, ist, wenn du anfängst zu draggen, willst du natürlich einen Snapshot von der Datei machen, die du dragst, nicht das...
Die sich dann ändert?
Die sich dann ändert, genau. Und wenn du sie dann droppst, willst du natürlich nicht dem Prozess, der dann die Datei gedroppt bekommt, Zugriff auf den Container der Quellapp geben, sondern du willst natürlich die Datei dann hintenrum über das Dateisystem auf der anderen Seite einblenden, sodass dann die gesnapshotte Datei in einem anderen Container erscheint. Und ich nehme mal an, dass sich das über APFS relativ einfach machen lässt.
Ja, das ist schon geil, muss man mal sagen.
Aber du kannst halt auch andere Sachen drag-and-dropen. Im Prinzip ist es ja so, bei einem Drag machst du so eine Art Pasteboard auf. Also Drag-and-Drop funktioniert technisch fast genauso wie Copy-and-Paste. Alles, was du machst, du packst in deinem Pasteboard Dinge, die den Empfänger interessieren können, könnten rein und sagst so, hier mein Drag, das sind diese Sachen da. Und außerdem ist noch dieses Image zum Draggen und bla bla bla. Und wenn der Drop dann passiert, bekommt die andere Seite halt das Pasteboard mit dem ganzen Kram, den du da reingemacht hast. Und da sind halt wie gesagt auch diese File-System, Promises mit drin und so weiter. Können aber auch Texte links und so weiter.
Da sind doch jede Menge Metadaten dabei, wer, was die Drag-Source ist und tralala und so, oder?
Ja, kann sein, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Also als Ziel kriegst du bestimmt noch mehr Daten, als das, was die Quelle da reingetan hat.
Das müsste ich mir nochmal genauer angucken. Bin ich jetzt überfragt. Aber du kannst halt so Sachen machen, wie wenn du einen Link von Safari zum Beispiel aus dragst, dann kriegst du halt nicht nur die URL, sondern du kriegst auch den Text von dem Link, also der blau untermalte Text und diesen ganzen Kram.
Okay.
Aber es ist wiederum, es entscheidet wiederum die Quelle, was packt sie alles rein? Und der Empfänger entscheidet, guckt in das Pasteboard rein und sagt, mit einem oder mehreren von diesen Dingen kann ich was anfangen und signalisiert dadurch, ich bin eine Destination, ich würde diesen Drop empfangen, ansonsten sagt er, geh weg.
Hallo, wir haben gerade, Herr Moderator, wir haben gerade Sendepause.
So, Control Center, da hattest du mich jetzt abgewürgt, ich hatte es, naja, also im Prinzip haben sie halt jetzt das, was vorher, wenn man von unten reingeswipet hat, dann hat man ja diese Controls bekommen. Flugmodus und Zeug und laut, leise, hell, dunkel, Screen Mirroring, ja ja, diesen ganzen Kram, genau. Und dann konntest du rechts swipen und dann hast du diese Player-Controls gekriegt und dann konntest du noch mal rechts swipen und dann hast du die Homekit-Dinger bekommen. Genau. Und das ist jetzt beim iPad zumindest alles auf einer Screen und zwar rechts von dem, was an offenen Dateien da ist. Das heißt, du hast diesen Unterschied zwischen, ich hab jetzt den Task-Switcher und ich hab jetzt diese Schnellzugriffs-Dinger und so weiter, hast du nicht mehr, sondern hast nur noch dieses eine Control-Center, was ich eigentlich relativ cool finde, dass das mal irgendwie aufgeräumt wurde, weil es wurden ja doch ein bisschen viele Drags und Swipes und haste nicht gesehen. Also es fühlt sich, also das Update, erste Beta auf dem iPad, sehr langsames iPad, langsamste Mini, wo es noch drauf läuft.
Welches ist das?
Das Retina, das allererste.
Das Zweier?
Du kannst es Zweier nennen, ja. Also das iPad Mini 2 bzw. das erste Retina, das ist halt langsam, aber es tut. Es ist einigermaßen solide. Manchmal stürzt es die Beta noch ab, aber im Prinzip kann man relativ gut sehen, wo die Reise hingeht, und es gefällt mir ganz gut. Schön ist auch das Dock da unten, weil man kann da beliebig, oder ich glaube so fast beliebig, da Programme reinschmeißen. Und ähnlich wie auf dem Mac-Dock werden die Kacheln immer kleiner.
Aber wie kommt denn dieses Dock überhaupt zustande? Ich war total überrascht, als ich gelesen habe, das Dock ist jetzt größer. Dock? Seit wann gibt es einen Dock?
Na du hattest doch vorher schon den Bereich da unten, der sich nicht ändert, wenn du blätterst. Also wir sind jetzt im Springboard, also in dem Bereich, wo die Apps sind. Da hattest du unten den Bereich, wo die Programme drin sind.
Ja, da gingen nur vier rein.
Genau, da gingen fünf. Vier oder fünf, genau. Vier auf dem iPhone. Fünf oder sechs auf dem iPad. Und da gehen jetzt jede Menge mehr rein, weil das wird einfach kleiner. Der Bereich, also die Icons werden kleiner. Es verhält sich sowieso überraschend ähnlich wie auf dem Mac. Und du hast rechts immer die drei Apps, die, sie nennen ja jetzt alles Siri, aber diese Siri-Vorschläge, also diese Vorschläge, von denen iOS meint, das sind die Apps, die du jetzt in deiner jetzigen Situation am wahrscheinlichsten brauchen wirst.
Ja, weil die dann halt im Doc sind. Ja, das ist sinnvoll. Mit 5 kam ich noch nie aus.
Find ich ganz gut gelungen. Also wenn man es dann hochkant macht, sieht man, es wird wirklich sehr klein.
Aber das iPad könnte noch mal richtig praktisch werden.
Also ich bin ganz angetan davon. Auf dem iPhone, ich hab's auch auf dem iPhone gemacht, die Beta, da ist es irgendwie so, ja okay, und jetzt? Aber auf dem iPad bringt es wirklich was.
Ich nutze mein iPad Pro jetzt auch häufiger als das alte. Und auch mehr als Rechner, so gerade wenn ich unterwegs bin. Was, ein iPad Pro?
Welches denn? Das große?
Das kleine. Vage ist jetzt sogar auf Reisen zu gehen, ohne Rechner mitzunehmen.
Nein!
Ja, es gibt jetzt inzwischen mehr oder weniger leitlich gut funktionierende SSH-Klines. Weil vorher, wie immer, immer der mich ohne Rechner unterwegs war, hat Murphy zugeschlagen, hat gesagt, ja, jetzt hab ich auf deinem Server gerade irgendwas kaputt gemacht. Das, ne, und SSH-Verbindung und so. Easy zu fixen, so mit zwei Kommando-Zeilen, aber die musst du erstmal irgendwo reindrücken können.
Aber das Komptool, das kennst du und das hast du...
Ja, ich weiß, hab ich auch auch probiert. Die haben alle diese Dinger, ich hab drei oder vier von diesen SSH-Klines drauf und einer tut's dann immer irgendwie. Aber es ist teilweise echt schlimm.
Die Empfehlung hast du auch nicht?
Ich hab jetzt eine, die funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut, aber dann drücke ich versehentlich die Emoji-Taste auf meiner Hardware-Tastatur und dann...
Emoji-Taste?
Ja, ich hab da so eine...
Was ist denn eine Emoji-Taste?
Na, das ist die Original-Apple.
Was hat eine Emoji-Taste?
Das Ding hat eine...
Und keine Escape-Taste?
Doch. Hat die eine Escape-Taste?
Die iPad-Tastaturen haben keine Escape-Taste, glaube ich.
Nee, die haben keine Escape-Taste. Ich editiere mal mit. Stimmt, da macht er so Software-Keys hin. Aber der hat hier unten diese Weltkugeltaste. Die erzeugt dann ein Emoji-Dingsen. Hat da... Doch, kann ich. Die haben unten noch so Soft-Keys da. Da ist dann da ein Escape. So ähnlich gibt es auch Sparren. Jetzt hab ich zwar eine Hardware-Tastatur, jetzt drücke ich diese Weltkugeltaste, dann kommt dir die Emojis da.
Ja, bei mir ist die Weltkugel mit FM.
Funktioniert ganz gut. Der iPad Pro ist fluffig schnell und so. Und den Stift hab ich auch. Da mach ich auch Sachen mit. Da wird's jetzt noch mal ein bisschen lustiger, weil's jetzt so Stifterkennung angeht. Machen sie jetzt noch ein paar schöne neue Sachen, hab ich gesehen, ne? Für iOS 11.
Ja, kann sein. Weiß ich nicht.
Was haben sie da gezeigt? Aber wie gesagt, ich nutze das sehr gerne inzwischen. Du machst jetzt hier gerade Bluetooth-Tests?
Was gab's noch? Ach ja, iOS 11 kann jetzt wirklich kein 32-Bit mehr. Das haben sie jetzt rausgeschmissen.
Also die ganzen Apps, wo immer sagt, diese App macht dein iPhone langsam, machen jetzt dein iPhone nicht mehr langsam. Weil sie gehen einfach nicht mehr.
Ja, die 64-Bit-Transition, also die haben sie ja ziemlich so en passant ausgerufen für iOS und für macOS.
Naja, aber nicht die Transition, sondern das Abschneiden des Zopfes. Wir haben ja schon transitiert.
Bei macOS beginnt das, was bei iOS jetzt mit 10, also sozusagen eine Version danach. Sie schneiden den Zopf erstmal bei iOS ab und danach kommen...
Wir zeigen einem jetzt schon mal die Schere.
Sie zeigen einem schon mal die Schere.
Ja, aber bei iOS haben sie die Schere ja jetzt auch eine ganze Weile hochgehalten.
Und gezeigt.
Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr noch Apps, die ihr vermissen werdet?
Ganz, ganz selten. Ich hab neulich mal wieder ausprobiert, da kam dann hoch, diese abmacht dein Telefon langsam und dann wusste ich ja, du weißt, dass du die alle auflisten kannst, ne? Ja, nämlich.
Du gehst in die Settings.
Warte langsam, alle Hörer klicken jetzt mit. Telefon müssen jetzt erstmal holen.
Alle Hörer müssen erstmal wieder aufwachen.
Hörer haben ihre Telefonhandel und Settings, ja.
Dann Allgemein oder General.
Dann Info.
Also der erste Punkt da.
Wie heißt der denn?
About. Genau, und dann Apps.
Gib mir eine Zahl.
Und dann kommt so eine lange Liste mit keine Updates verfügbar.
Nee, kommt hier keine lange Liste.
Ich hab auch keine lange Liste. Ich hab hier no Updates available.
Ja und...
Monkey Island Special Edition.
App Compatibility heißt so bei mir in Englisch.
Genau, Abkompatibilität.
Wo sind da die Apps?
Da sind Apps. Hab ich schon gemacht, passiert genau nichts.
Er kann bei sich nicht draufklicken.
Hast du keine 32-Bit-Apps?
Ach, er zeigt mir 32-Bit-Apps. Ich hab 32-Bit-Apps.
Eine App, die ich auf jeden Fall vermissen werde, ist Pollen Pro. Das ist nämlich das für mich sinnvollste Interface für einen Pollen-Radar. Und immer wenn ich Screenshots poste, warum es mir gerade schlecht geht, dann fragen alle Leute, was ist das für eine App? Was ist das für eine App? Und ich sag denen ja, die gibt es seit Jahren schon nicht mehr im App-Store, aber die Daten werden, also die Datenquelle funktioniert immer noch und das zeigt immer noch akkurat und für mich ausreichend gut an, welche Pollen-Belastung ich zu erwarten habe, seit der Heuschnuff. Und wenn die weggehen würde, dann müsste ich mir nochmal von irgendjemandem erklären lassen, wie man so eine ganz stumpfe App in dieser Hinsicht nachquoten könnte, weil das werde ich sehr vermissen.
Die Swift Sandbox gibt es in einer neuen Version, kannst du einfach loslegen, ganz easy.
Pollen-Wochenende.
Was hab ich denn hier? Also ich hab, abgesehen von so ein paar Kindergames, die nicht sein müssen. Google Earth, denke ich, man kriegt dann doch vielleicht noch ein Update oder jetzt Dead Gym, aber es ist eigentlich auch nicht wirklich nutz-nützlich.
Und wird ja bei mir nicht gelistet, das Google Earth. Hab ich Google Earth? Ach nee, ich hab Google Maps, nee, ich hab kein Google Earth, mal genau.
Genau. Und was leider auch fallen wird, ist eine App namens Stereoscope.
Genau, seh ich auch hier.
Echt, hast du noch auf deinem Teil?
Der Postion News-Ticker.
Outbank 2 hab ich noch, Flight Control, Zen Garden 2048, Smart Soko-Bahn, blitzer.de, Hard Logic, das was ich hier vor ein paar Folgen mal gesagt hab, was so ein tolles Spiel ist, Mumble, Shoebox, das ist auch so ein Scanner-App, was halt das Bild denn gerade macht hier, was Apple gerade vorgestellt hat, Seismometer und Epyx Citadel.
Ehrlich gesagt, was mir an diesem Screen fehlt, ist der Swipe nach links, um die Apps dann auch zu löschen. Also weil das ist eine schöne Auswahl an Apps, die ich jetzt einfach auch löschen könnte. Also da ist ein Taschenrechner, Acoustic Ruler ist hier.
Ja, das ist schade mit Acoustic Ruler.
Gibt's einen Resistor-Call, also ein Taschenrechner für Widerstandswerte mit diesem Farbring.
Acoustic Ruler, da müssen wir dem Developer nochmal schreiben, das geht nicht, der kann das nicht fallen lassen. Das ist so ein Tool, damit kannst du, also eigentlich war es dafür gedacht, deswegen heißt es auch so, dass du Abstände mit deinem Kopfhörer messen kannst. Das heißt, du nimmst, schließt das Standard-Kabelheadset an, dann macht er so Töne drauf.
Schnackel-Sound.
Und misst quasi so die Phasenverschiebung und dann hat der Phasenverschiebung...
Na ja, die Laufzeit, nicht die Phasenverschiebung, aber...
Na ja, also anhand...
Der Laufzeit.
Der Phasenverschiebung, die Laufzeit.
Wie auch immer.
Er misst die Laufzeit. Eine Phasenverschiebung würde er nur messen, wenn es tatsächlich ein einzelner Sinus-Ton ist. Ist es aber nicht. Er misst die Laufzeit.
Okay, also er misst die Laufzeit, wie lange da von dem einen Kopfhörer, also er spielt quasi auf dem einen Kopfhörer, welcher ist links, welcher ist rechts, rechts ist der mit dem Mikrofon. Genau, also er spielt dem linken Kopfhörer was ab, was halt mit dem Mikrofon aufgenommen wird. Am Anfang hältst du sie direkt aneinander, dann weiß er quasi so, kalibriert er sich auf Null, und dann kannst du da halt irgendwas mit abmessen. Das ist eigentlich so ein totales Tool, wo man sich denkt, warum sollte ich mit meinem Kopfhörer strecken ausmessen, wenn ich das auch mit einem Lineal machen kann. Aber der Ralf ist ja immer ganz pfiffig, also hier Ralf Stockmann, Ultraschall und so weiter, Gas bei Freak Show, ist dann auf die Idee gekommen, naja, wenn das Ding irgendwie mit der Laufzeit den Abstand misst, dann kann man damit ja auch die Laufzeit messen. Und wir haben das benutzt, um Latenzmessungen an Headsets zu machen. Das heißt, um zu wissen, wie die Latenz ist, quasi von irgendeinem Ding, hältst du einfach das Headset ran mit Acoustic Ruler und dann hast du halt von so einer Kopfhörer-Mikrofon-Kombination kannst du halt mal eben die Latenz messen.
Das war praktisch.
Einfach so ein Latenzmesser. Ohne, dass du halt Recording-Software dafür aufbauen musst.
Diese Steps, die wir gerade durchgeführt haben, um die abgelaufenen Apps irgendwie zu entdecken, ist dein Telefon auch in Englisch?
Nein. In Deutsch? Du hast dein Telefon auf Deutsch?
Weil bei ihm klappt es irgendwie weder beim iPhone, noch beim iPad und er hat seins halt in Deutsch. Deswegen dachte ich, vielleicht haben die einen Deutschen das noch nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, ich hab's auch auf Deutsch.
Okay, okay, dann ist das ausgedacht. Dann weiß ich nicht, was bei Clemens kaputt ist.
Wir hören nicht nicht.
Setz mal dein Ding ins Wiederauf. Allgemein Info, genau. Und dann gibt's Apps, bei mir sind es 225.
Zwischen Fotos und Kapazität.
Was, du hast nur 225 Apps auf deinem Telefon? Bist ja gar kein Power-User. Wie viel hast du drauf?
265.
Und du, Dennis?
70. Mein Phone hat nur 64 GIG.
Und ich hab 378. Ich hab gewonnen.
Nein, hast du nicht.
Was machst du jetzt? Du drückst ja jetzt drauf? Oder ist das irgendwie, drück mal da drauf.
Da ist ein Pfeil bei mir.
Bei mir ist da auch ein Pfeil, ja. Vielleicht hast du einfach gar keine. Oder was hast du denn hier? Du hast ja noch ein Software-Update nicht installiert.
Na natürlich nicht.
Wollen wir auch damit mahnen.
Wieso hast du noch iOS 8 drauf oder was?
Ich hab jetzt noch keine Zeit gehabt.
Stell dich jetzt drück download, bevor er was dagegen tun kann.
Von wegen, wir konvertieren mal ein Pfeilsystem on the fly, möchte man vielleicht doch vorher ein Backup von machen.
Welches hast du denn jetzt? 10.2? Na ja, dann hast du das Feature halt noch nicht. Es gibt ja erst das 10.3.
Du hast seit zwei Monaten keinen Backup gemacht?
Ich hatte noch keine Zeit.
Und du backerst mit Tim, weil der Raid null fährt?
Wegen der Freak Show hier. Das andere mach ich ja alle Backup.
Ich habe gerade keinen Backup. Jetzt wie so ein richtiger Shaming-Podcast hier.
So und gerade hatte ich, warte einen Moment, wir waren jetzt, stopp, wir waren jetzt bei 64 Pizzen, wir waren damit durch.
Ja, ich würde sagen, eine Kleinigkeit zum Thema iOS würde ich gerne noch loswerden und zwar HomeKit. Das interessante an HomeKit ist, dass es jetzt auch eine Non-Commercial-License gibt für die gesamte, diesen gesamten HomeKit-Kram und dass, wie es da so schön steht, die Authentifizierung keinen Hardware-Chip mehr benötigt. Also der Weg ist jetzt offiziell frei, mit Arduinos und Raspberry Pis und so weiter HomeKit-Accessories zu basteln. Ich erwarte da entsprechenden Output von der Community. Sag ich mal.
Weiß ich nicht, ob die Community da so schnell reagiert, aber die Anforderungen an Authentication sind immer noch relativ hoch. Nehm ich mal an.
Die Anforderungen sind die gleichen, aber man kann sie jetzt auch in Software erledigen.
Also wenn das jemand kann, dann glaube ich die Community.
Ja, können tut sie das natürlich auf jeden Fall. Ob sie sich jetzt schon ermutigt fühlt, da zuzuspielen, das werden wir dann sehen. Aber HomeKit ist in dringendem Bedarf nach alternativen Sensoren, Triggern und anderen Dingen. Weil da ist einfach mal das Angebot zu sehen, dass Apple das da auch bejubelt hat. Das ist einfach mal echt dünne.
Und die Scheiße ist echt teuer. Ich mach jetzt mal ein Blanko-Angebot. Jeder, der zum Kongress eine selbst gebastelte HomeKit-Lösung mitbringt, die zeige ich bei der Freak Show auf der Bühne.
Insofern wir mit der Freak Show da auf der Bühne sind.
Na ja, wenn nicht, dann stelle ich mich irgendwo in die Ecke.
Also hier unsere Feinstaubfreunde könnten gleich mal anfangen.
Weil der Feinstaubsensor nämlich auch Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit misst. Und da der sowieso draußen hängt, hätte ich dann gleich mal Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Das war das Paket, was ich im Sinne hatte. Uns hat auch jemand einen Feinstaubsensor zugeschickt. Aber den habe ich jetzt glaube ich oben gelassen.
So, so, in die eigene Tasche wieder gewunscht.
Wie war der?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe das nur kurz gesehen.
Also ich hatte in der Sendung mal angesagt, dass ich gerne einen hätte.
Vielleicht ist er für dich. Das kann schon sein.
Da liegt er natürlich bei dir oben. Richtig.
Alle, alle wollen...
Ich hätte ihn ja gleich mitgenommen und so könnte ich ihn halt vielleicht noch behalten.
Alle wollen einen Feinstaubsensor haben.
Aha. Na ja gut, ich schlage nochmal nach. Ich bin gerade etwas überrascht. Ich dachte, ich hätte das Paket mitgenommen, aber irgendwie... Ja, das führte dann auch zu dieser Konfusion.
Vielleicht hast du den Holgi mitgegeben.
Nee, Holgi war ja schon seit Jahren nicht mehr hier. Der Herr macht ja keine Termine mit mir.
Nicht?
Für NSFW. Ja.
Ist sich jetzt zu verändern zu?
Ich wollte ja eine Sendung machen. Nächste Woche habe ich einen Termin. Aber der Feindeherr hat keine Zeit.
Wer ist denn der Feindeherr?
Holgi. Nase.
Hört ihr eh nicht zu. So ist er.
Ich sammle hier Daten.
So, weiter.
Wo waren wir denn jetzt? HomeKit. Ja, und HomeKit hat auch so neue Features mit. Du kannst jetzt irgendwie mehr abgefahrene Träger zusammenbauen, die in Abhängigkeit von irgendwas sind. Und so... halt so für alle möglichen Szenarien und so kann unterscheiden, ob Leute im Haus sind oder nicht, wie sie es genau machen, weil sie jetzt nicht so ganz genau einschränken und wiederholen die Events. Also HomeKit, nur zum Verständnis, hat ja quasi in dem System sozusagen diese ganzen Trigger und Event-Dinger mit drin. Das ist so eine Art Action-Framework, was du quasi mit HomeKit-Apps so konfigurieren und bearbeiten kannst. Aber die liegen so in dem System und das System löst die so selber aus.
Ja, ist ein bisschen so clicky-bunt und wenig Programmieren, sondern mehr so drei Schalter umlegen und dann passiert was automatisieren.
Ja, so in drei Phasen und dann hast du so Szenen, die so aktiviert werden. Ich hab damit bisher auch nichts aktivieren, also nichts automatisieren können, was ich wirklich hätte automatisieren wollen.
Also ich hab halt ein Fenstersensor und ein Heizkörper, Ding Sie, und wenn ich das Fenster aufmache, geht der Heizkörper in die Ich-gehe-jetzt-aus-Szene. Und wenn ich das Fenster wieder zumache, geht der Heizkörper wieder in die Ich-bin-jetzt-ans-Szene.
Ja, dafür ist es irgendwie sinnvoll, aber diese Konstellation hab ich halt nicht, weil ich hab viel zu viele Fenster und keinen einzigen Heizkörper, der irgendwie damit ausgerüstet ist, wo es Sinn machen würde, weil das macht halt so mit meinem Steuergerät keinen Sinn. Das hatten wir ja alles schon mal. Das hat alles nicht funktioniert. Auch so mit Türen, Sensoren, kann man irgendwie auch relativ wenig anfangen. Und komischerweise konnte man halt nicht so einfache Sachen machen, wie wenn die Temperatur über einem bestimmten Wert ist, dann schickt mir mal eine Nachricht oder irgendwie sowas. Solche einfachen Sachen gehen einfach gar nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, ob Apple da den richtigen Weg geht. Sie geben sich irgendwie Mühe, aber it's not for me today.
Okay, weiter.
Brauchen wir weiter bei Software bleiben oder wollen wir jetzt endlich mal über Hardware reden?
Gibt es da in Software noch irgendwas?
Nee, oder?
Ja, es gibt noch so diese networking-Geschichte, die Clemens zum Beispiel angesprochen hat.
Ja, aber da kann man zusammenfassen. Schaut euch den Talk an von Stuart Schescher.
Nee, das ist aber wirklich Quatsch.
Es gibt jetzt ECN, da haben sie jetzt grundsätzlich angeknipstet.
Ja, vor zwei Jahren.
Explicit Congestion Notification. Das heißt, die App sagt jetzt lieber Router auf dem Weg von mir zu meinem Server oder der Server, der da hoffentlich mitspielt, sagt das auch für seine Pakete, sagt, sag mir doch lieber Bescheid, anstatt einfach meine Pakete wegzuschmeißen, wenn dir was nicht passt. Das betrifft insbesondere, wie Stuart auch so schön erzählt, natürlich gerade den Bottleneck bei euch zu Hause, weil bei den meisten Leuten, die zum Beispiel mit DSL-Anstoß oder auch mit Kabelmodems oder so arbeiten, ist die physische Bitrate, die zu ihnen nach Hause führt, ja in der Regel deutlich größer als das, was ihnen der Provider gibt. Das heißt, der Provider erzeugt dort künstlichen Bottleneck und das wird halt dadurch implementiert, dass da einfach Pakete weggeschmissen werden. Und das ist halt ungünstig, weil das halt mehr Aufwand zeugt, weil jeder Paket kommt wieder und bringt Brüder und Schwestern mit. Und deswegen gibt es diesen Mechanismus, wo man gesagt hat, wir haben hier noch ein paar Bits, die brauchen wir ja sonst nicht in den IP-Headern. Die widmen wir mal dafür um, dass man damit mal ansagen kann, lieber Ruta, bevor du meine Pakete wegschmeißt, weil wir jetzt hier irgendwelche Q-Sizes überschreiten oder sonst sowas, sag mir doch lieber Bescheid, denn sende ich weniger. Das hat eine Weile gedauert, bis das durchging, weil es gab noch irgendwelche uralten IPv4 Firewalls von 1874, die sich gewundert haben, die diese Bits da machen und dann die Pakete komplett weggeschmissen haben, aber inzwischen ist es so, dass man das einfach machen kann. Und Apple hat das jetzt lange Zeit getestet und macht das jetzt einfach mal an. Das heißt, du hast besseren Durchsatz, weniger Congestion, schnellere Reaktionszeiten, deine Streams bleiben nicht dauernd immer mal stecken und also Zeugs, wenn das alles korrekt implementiert ist, auch auf den Netzdingern. Auf der Serverseite zu implementieren ist relativ easy. Die Operator müssen das jetzt gerade an die Energies machen, also an den Access-Routern zu den Leuten draußen.
Das heißt, das iPhone oder das Mac OS sagt dann Bescheid, ich kann jetzt nicht so schnell, mach mal langsamer?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ja, ne. Das iPhone fordert das erstmal an. Das iPhone sagt erstmal, ich bin an dieser Information interessiert. Das ist ja in die eine Richtung. Das heißt, das muss dann in den Paketen, die dir wieder zurückkommen, muss das entsprechend zurückgetragen werden. Also wenn jetzt was ist, ist immer nur interessant für den Sender. Der Sender sendet irgendwas, der Empfänger hat eh keine Einfluss darauf, wie was ankommt. Aber der Sender sendet jetzt seinen Paketstrom und wenn irgendjemand auf dem Weg zwischen dem Sender und dem Empfänger, der zu viel ist, machen sie das momentan, regulieren sie das dadurch, dass sie Pakete wegschmeißen und hoffen, dass die involvierten TCP-Stacks das rausfinden und entsprechend langsamer senden. Das funktioniert auch, aber sehr leidlich und dazu werden erst mal jede Menge Pakete weggeschmissen unnötigerweise, die dann erst wieder retried werden müssen, bis die weiße Chain merkt, dass das so ist. Jetzt sagt man, ich schicke ihr ein Paket und alle Leute auf dem Weg, an denen dieses Paket vorbeikommt, wenn ihr Sorgen damit habt, weil es jetzt zu viel ist euch, dann schickt mir die Indikation zurück, ihr kann damit klarkommen, schickt mir dieses ECN-Bit, dieses Congestion-Bit auf demselben Stream und dann sende ich langsamer, dann höre ich auf, euch vollzukacken, damit ihr nicht dauernd immer meine Pakete wegschmeißen müsst.
Noch mal meine Frage, also das OS ist jetzt in der Lage, diese Dinge auch zu schicken.
Das ist schon eine Weile.
Ja, aber was ist dann die News?
Die News ist tatsächlich jetzt immer anmachen. Früher war das so, da musste die Applikation extra sagen, ich will das haben, dann hat Apple das mal testweise angemacht auf ein paar Verbindungen oder sowas, weil sie immer noch dachten, oh das gibt bestimmt irgendwelche Firewalls auf diesem Planeten, die kommen damit nicht klar und so, aber jetzt haben sie das lange genug getestet, dass sie jetzt sagen, das ist jetzt safe genug, das immer anzumachen. Das heißt der Colonel macht das einfach für dich, weil sie jetzt der Meldung sind, dass sie damit im Internet durchkommen, ohne sich dabei Ärger einzutreten. So, der zweite ist, was sie auch haben, aus der Networking-Geschichte, finde ich auch sehr gut, ist dieses MPTCP, also Multipath TCP, was sie schon eine Weile drin haben, was sie derzeit nur für Siri benutzen, testweise, bieten sie jetzt auch Applikationsentwicklern an.
Okay, das ist geil.
Und da musst du auch, du kannst, also es gibt so drei Modi, in denen man das betreiben kann. Zwei von denen bietet Apple an, und die dritte nur für Beta, also zum Testen innerhalb des Hauses. Nämlich, dass du sagst, ich möchte gerne Low Latency haben, das ist mir sehr wichtig. Ich möchte gerne, dass schnell meine Daten durchkommen. Ich schicke auch nicht viel, also dass du zum Beispiel Siri benutztet. Weil sie wollen gerne, dass das ein bisschen snappy ist, dass du was sagst zu Siri. In der Siri musst du ja erstmal einpacken, die Sprache, also Arbeit, mach da eine Vorbereitung für, schick das dann an den Siri-Server, der was daraus macht und möchtest gerne möglichst schnell eine Reaktion darauf haben. Und das machen sie halt eben, die Story geht so, dass sie sagen, man benutzt, weil sie haben festgestellt, dass man Siri gerne in Grenzsituationen benutzt. Nämlich, du gehst aus dem Haus, bist also gerade dabei, dein eigenes Home-Netz zu verlassen, stehst dann vor der Tür und fragst Siri irgendwas. Wann kommt der nächste Bus, wie wird das Wetter oder sonst irgendwas? Keine Ahnung, ob das realistisch ist oder nicht. Sie sagen, das kommt halt eben sehr häufig vor. Deswegen machen sie da Multipart TCP bei Siri immer über das Wi-Fi-Netz und über das Mobilfunk-Netz und sagen, wichtig ist mir, dass diese wenigen Datenmengen, die wir schicken, sie schicken nur ein paar 100 bytes oder so was dafür. Aber die möchten bitte gerne demnächst mal ankommen und nicht noch 100 Mal retried werden auf deinem Wi-Fi-Hotspot, der eh schon viel zu weit weg ist oder sonst irgendwas. Sondern möchte das jetzt möglichst gerne zum Server durchprügeln. Der dritte Modus ist, der zweite Modus ist, was du sagst, ich möchte gerne, ich weiß gar nicht, das erste war Latency, der zweite war... Nee, nee, throughput gerade. Das ist der dritte Modus.
Für jetzt Multipath-CCP. Weiß nicht, hast du das jetzt schon erwähnt, dass wenn irgendwie andere den Router irgendwie zuballern mit ihren Downloads, dass du dann deine Achsen nicht kriegst und dass du dann die über den zweiten Kanal machen kannst?
Genau. Das ist so Reliability oder so. Dass du eben sagst, ich möchte gerne steady was durchhagen. Der dritte Modus ist der, ich erwähne es jetzt deswegen, weil mich eh wieder 500 Leute über Twitter darüber fragen müssen. Ja, man kann darüber auch Verbindungen bündeln. Man kann dann WLAN und LTE gleichzeitig benutzen, um mehr Durchsatz zu haben. Den bieten sie aber explizit nicht an, sondern nur zum Testen für Test-Applikationen im Beta. Das bieten sie nicht Endkunden an, weil sie genau wieder wissen, dass sie dafür verklagt werden.
Ich frage mich, ob man damit irgendwie auch so, also dieses Problem mit ich gehe aus dem Haus raus, das ist ja jetzt nicht nur für Siri ein Problem. Das ist zum Beispiel immer bei Streaming und bei Voice-Telefonie zum Beispiel.
Das ist auch bei ganz anderen Apps ein Problem. Du fängst halt an, dein scheiß BVG-Klicke zu ticken.
Ja, aber Audio-Streaming. Audio-Streaming ist halt besonders krass, weil du willst halt überhaupt nichts verlieren. Das heißt, wenn du in der Lage bist, gleichzeitig über LTE sozusagen schon so mitzuhören mit irgendwie, ja, würde hier auch was kommen und in dem Moment, wo du so viel lang abkackt, dass du auch wirklich die...
Ach so, ne, geht wieder mal nicht. Meine Rolls-Royce-Bataste. Ach ne, ich hab jetzt hier die, Entschuldigung, ich hab die falsche Rolls-Royce-Bataste.
Jetzt noch mal bitte rollstand, genau, besser. Jeder nur einen Kreuz.
Jeder auch mit seiner Rolls-Royce-Bataste?
Mach schon drei, ey.
Ich brauch mir noch mal eine Rolls-Royce-Bataste für euch alle vier.
So eine Rolls-Royce-Bataste, bitte.
Aber egal, es ist diese Reliability-Geschichte, dass du sagst, ich möchte jetzt gerne das da durchhaben. Ja, dass ich ja nichts verliere. So und das bieten sie jetzt. Apple bietet das jetzt nicht bloß Siri an, sondern sie verwenden das selber für all möglichen Scheiß und sie bieten es jetzt auch Applikationen an. Und zwar relativ einfach. Wenn ihr deren Framework wieder benutzt, die sagen, eh nutzt unser Framework, auf selber Sockets aufzumachen, dann habt ihr auch keine Probleme mit IPv6 oder sonst. Und nutzt einfach dieses komische, wie heißt das Rolli? NSOL... NSOL Session, wie auch immer. Ja, nutzt dieses Framework, macht das alles für euch. Da kannst du jetzt einfach nur Parameter angeben.
Sowieso alles für dich, das zu benutzen, nicht zu benutzen und der iOS ist total doof.
Ja, da gibt's jetzt wie gesagt noch die Parameter, dass du jetzt optional sagen kannst, mach mal hier Multipart damit.
Wenn ich was Spezielles machen will, wie ein Stream oder so, dann ist es nicht das Richtige. Aber wenn ich einfach nur eine URL öffnen will, irgendwo ein Get-Request, dann gibt's keine gute Entschuldigung, es nicht zu benutzen.
So, löst halt wie gesagt auch IPv6-Thematiken und so weiter und so fort, wenn man die überhaupt hat. Apple sagt, wenn es für den Multipart TCP geht, du brauchst deine Server-Unterstützung dafür. Die fördern, wenn sie nicht sogar selber aktiv involviert sind, diese Open-Source-Geschichte, also mptcp.org oder wie sowas, wo du dir denn Colonel oder Colonel-Erweiterungen runterladen kannst. Die gehen sogar hin und sagen, pass mal auf, wir wissen alle, dass ihr alle zu faul und zu doof dafür seid. Hier hast du ein fertiges Ding für ein AWS oder für ein Google Compute Engine oder sonst irgendwas. Ein Colonel, also was, der dir das einfach macht. So fertig. Zack. Das fertige Container, wie auch immer das heißt. In dieser Szene.
mptcp.org Nein, ob ich jetzt nichts mp...
Ich muss noch mal auf diesem Talk da nachgucken von Stuart und Co. Also, wie heißt dieses Projekt? mptcp.org oder so. Glaube ich. Auch nicht. Doch mal mp-... Jedenfalls, also Apple sagt jetzt nicht nur...
multipartccp.org Das heißt, nee, Linux Colonel, meinste das hier? Nee.
Könnte sein, ja. Ich guck noch mal an dem Talk nach.
Das ist jetzt für Linux.
Deswegen hab ich vorhin noch gefragt, ob es so weit jetzt auch einen tollen FreeBSD11 gibt, aber das wissen wir ja, wie gesagt, nicht. Aber Apple sagt jetzt auch jetzt hier, nicht nur baut ihr dann eure Apps ein, sondern hier, ihr ganzen Cloud-Hipsa. Hier hast du das Amazon-Zeugs oder das Google Cloud... Google Compute Engine-Dingsten und Spaß haben. Fertig.
Kann man machen. Sollte man auch tun. Dann haben sie noch irgendwie erzählt, dass sie jetzt TCP aus dem Kernel ins User-Land verschieben.
Ja.
Aus Performance-Gründen.
Ist mir noch nicht ultimativ klar, warum.
Aus Performance-Gründen kommt mir komisch vor, weil man macht ja normalerweise Dinge im Kernel aus Performance-Gründen. Und nicht im User-Land.
Aber... Ich muss mal den Teil nochmal genauer angucken. Sie machen es jetzt so noch nicht mit iOS 11, aber Stuart hat sich da auf die Bühne gestellt und gesagt, so hier, das machen wir jetzt so demnächst mal, steckt euch drauf ein.
Na ja, es hat, also es mag auch, also wir haben Performance-Gründe angegeben. Deine Aussage mit, man macht das im Kernel aus Performance-Gründen, würde ich jetzt so nicht pauschal unterschreiben. Also der Kernel ist jetzt nicht per se schneller, sondern traditionell.
Es ist das Netzwerk, was sie auch bei Linux und FreeBSD und so weiter benutzt. Das sind so italienische Entwickler hauptsächlich, glaube ich. Das ist so, du kriegst die Pakete direkt, also der Kernel macht natürlich schon Netzwerk, aber der jagt dich nicht mehr durch seinen Stack, sondern du kriegst direkt die TCP-Pakete in deine App rein. Das ist so für TCP-Dump zum Beispiel toll. Der kriegt direkt so einen Stream und die können dann wirklich auch die Gigabits dann abfeiern, weil der Kernel sich da gar nicht weiter größer drum kümmern muss. Das heißt, bei Freebase nennt ihr das, glaube ich, Netmap.
Was heißt direkt den TCP-Stream? Den kriegst du ja auch sonst auch direkt.
Ja, aber der ist schon durch den TCP-IP-Stack durchgewandert. Wo kriegst du denn genau, kriegst du das direkt wo durch?
Also du kriegst die Pakete ohne, dass sie sortiert wurden. Ja, aber das ist es hier nicht so. Das ist hier so, dass sie TCP und UDP in so ein Framework-Level verlegt haben. Also es läuft halt im Userspace. Und ist damit halt dem User-Scheduling unterworfen. Und damit halt mehr abhängig von deiner App sozusagen, was sie tatsächlich bekommt. Keine Ahnung, die werden sich das schon ausgerechnet haben. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht der einzige Grund, weil sie meinten auch noch, dass damit quasi alle BSD-basierten Network-Filter-Extensions halt demnächst nicht mehr funktionieren würden. Und du musst halt ihr Network-Extension-System benutzen, um künftig halt auf TCP-Ebene und so weiter Filtering etc., andere Dienste, was auch immer da alles abläuft.
Also da muss ich mich nochmal forschen, was das soll, was die Hintergründe dafür sind. Weil damit schmeißen sie eine ganze, ganze, ganze Menge um. Da gibt's einen Talk zu, aber sie sagen, ne, wir machen das so, weil wir das toll finden, aber jetzt die genauen Details. Aber ich sehe ja ein paar von den Fuzzies wieder jetzt in Prag zur ITF. Wenn man fragen, alter, what gives? Hier hast du ein Bier, spill it.
Spill the beer?
Gut, weiter im Text.
Also 2014 wurde noch dran gearbeitet an M...
Ein FreeBSD. Eine Kleinigkeit noch zu iOS 11, der neue Videoplayer. Oder überhaupt auch dieses ich mach lauter und leiser und ich hab nicht mehr dieses riesen Lautsprechersymbol mitten in der Mitte auf dem Bild, das man auch nicht wegmachen kann, sondern da gibt's jetzt irgendwie rechts in der Oben, in der Ecke, nur eine kleine Anzeige, dass du jetzt lauter oder leiser gemacht hast an deinen Tasten und hast es nicht mehr direkt im Bild. Das find ich sehr schön. Also der neue Playern gefällt mir dann doch deutlich besser. Besonders halt auch so Sachen, wie du machst am Bluetooth-Lautsprecher lauter oder leiser, der zeigt dir trotzdem dieses Ding an, weil natürlich dir über Bluetooth irgendwie dem Phone mitgeteilt wird, dass es lauter oder leiser zu tun hat.
Ja, es ist am Ende nichts anderes als die Tasten auch. Apple Maps macht jetzt irgendwie Spuranzeige im Navi und sie haben irgendwie Indoor und jetzt können sie auch Tegel hier irgendwie aufschlüsseln und sagen, wo man...
Und Schönefeld.
Ja, stand beides in der Liste.
Ok, ich hab nur Tegel gesehen, aber das finde ich ja schon mal bemerkenswert, dass sie da Berlin immer so...
Es ist jetzt auch echt nicht schwierig.
Na, die haben doch jetzt hier ein Büro in Mitte, da müssen sie natürlich auch die Berliner Flughäfen machen.
Die hatten doch so ein komisches Video, so ein Developer-Wir-sind-alle-toll-Video.
Das ist auch ein Berliner Dinger.
Mit 1.000 und 1.000 Szenen aus Berlin.
Stimmt, das stimmt. Apokalypse-Ding, oder?
Nee, die sind Apolope, die sind andere. Wir sind alle so tolle Developer. Developer, Developer, Developer, Developer.
Die Stadt, die da zu sehen war, war glaube ich fast nur aus Schleswig-Berlin.
Das stimmt, das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Vielleicht haben sie einfach nur eine Berliner Werbeagentur beauftragt, das Ding zu drehen.
Oder es ist einfach mal so cool hier. Ich mag das ja auch. Das wissen wir ja. Man wird ja auch selbst cooler dadurch, dass man in Berlin wohnt. Das färbt ja ab.
Allein schon, dass man sagt, man kommt aus Berlin.
Mehr muss man gar nicht sagen. Man muss auch nichts mehr sein oder können. Schon ist man cool.
Die Pessimisten fragen noch, bist du da wirklich geboren?
Und deine Eltern auch hier geboren? Nein. Ich bin deswegen nämlich gebürtig.
Geht auch kacken. Ist doch so unwichtig.
Geboren und gebürtig macht einen Unterschied.
Für wen jetzt nochmal?
Für die Leute, die gebürtig sind. Ihr alle mit euren Westgewurzeln. Gebürtig bedeutet, dass deine Eltern auch da geboren sind, wo du geboren bist.
Und wenn nur ein Elternteil da geboren ist?
Dann bist du gebore-dig oder sowas.
Gebore-dig?
Keine Ahnung, kriegst du auch nach bei Duden.
Wir sind einfach bekloppt orientiert. Ist alles vollkommen unwichtig. Berliner ist man per Akklamation.
Ach so, weil Tim ist ja keiner.
Und die muss nicht mal auf Deutsch sein.
Wieso ist er nun mal so in dieser Stadt? Ihr bist ja Berliner, wenn ihr dich dazu bekennt.
Niemand ist berlinerischer als der Schwabe, der gerade erst ein halbes Jahr da ist.
Ich bin ein Berliner. Ich bin ein Berliner.
Verlassen wir den rassistischen Kontext und betrachten weitere, andere Aspekte.
Das ist jetzt keine Frage der Rasse.
Nein, Rassismus bezieht sich ja nicht auf Rasse, sondern auf generell das Behalten, was sich unter anderem auch bei der Diskussion von Rassen zeigt, aber eben nicht ausschließlich darauf bezogen ist, wie auch immer.
Wie auch immer.
Das sollte doch bekannt sein.
Ok, Software haben wir jetzt durch?
Ja, ich könnte noch ein kleines Software-Ding, was unrelated ist, so wie wir die Zeter dazwischen schmeißen. Damit ich es nicht vergesse, weil ihr das ja auch immer macht. Und jetzt mach ich das auch mal.
Wie machen wir das?
Das haben wir von dir. Von wem denn sonst?
Ich hatte neulich mal wieder das Problem, dass ich so ein größeres Papierdokument als PDF haben wollte. Eine Betriebsanleitung für ein Gerät. Die war sehr umfangreich. Und die war auch sehr informativ. Jetzt habe ich natürlich den Vorteil, wenn ich das irgendwie getrennt bekomme von seiner Heftung und dann in meinen Scanner lege, dann kriege ich das gescannt. Doppelseitig alles pipapo, OCR, man kann darin suchen. Aber so eine Bedienungsanleitung will man nicht unbedingt immer nur durchsuchen, sondern man will auch mal ein Inhaltsverzeichnis haben. Und das machen die Dinger ja nicht.
Aber da gibt es ja Firmen, die machen dir das.
Ja, aber ich dachte mir so, vielleicht gibt es ja auch eine App dafür. Turns out, gibt's. Heißt PDF, Outliner.
Na, dass du da drauf anspringst, ist ja klar.
Klar, aber da hat der Outliner einen Appstore eingegeben, dann sind alle Programme mit Outliner aufgehobt und der hat alles gut gefetzt.
Du müsstest jetzt eigentlich nur noch Kalenderfunktionen haben, dann wär's perfekt.
Kalender, Outliner. Dann geht ihm einer ab.
Aber das ist... Ja, soll ich noch erzählen oder nicht?
Ja, bitte.
Wir sind ganz heiß.
Ja, also das Tool macht im Wesentlichen das, was man so denkt. Das heißt, du machst dir halt ein PDF auf und dann gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Angenommen, du hast nur so ein PDF, das aus so einem Microsoft Word-Dokument, aber ohne Inhaltsverzeichnis erzeugt wurde. Oder was vielleicht ein Inhaltsverzeichnis hat.
Aber ein generiertes PDF, kein gescanntes.
Genau, also ich rede jetzt von einem generierten PDF. Dann hast du ja den Vorteil, dass du da kein OCR brauchst und dass die Texte vollständig sind. Und dass du auch noch die Font-Informationen als solche drin hast. Und dann hat das Ding so eine automatische Table of Contents-Funktion, die ich jetzt nicht wirklich habe testen können, ob sie auf solcher Art Dokumente wirklich gut funktioniert, weil ich sowas gerade nicht zur Hand hatte. ZB mein Bedarf lag primär gerade auf dem anderen Ding. Aber ich habe es halt damit probiert, dass es halt nicht funktioniert. Sie meinen, es hätte bessere Chancen zu funktionieren mit eben Sachen, wo das so ist. Aber man kann halt auch wunderbar manuell das anlegen. D.h. du kannst ja so Zeile für Zeile, die ganze Hierarchie zusammenklicken, setzt vorher so mit einem Doppelklick irgendwo auf einer Seite den Bezugspunkt für dieses Table of Contents Ding. Und dann sagst du am Ende Save. Und dann hast du einen PDF, mit dem du das verzeichnest. Geiles Ding. Meine Entdeckung 5 Euro oder so. Hat nicht mehr gekostet, glaube ich.
Hier Clemens. Kurzes Update, also es ist ein Freebase Day Foundation Project, also gefundetes Project, Multipass TCP in Freebase Day zu kriegen. Und es gibt einen Experimental Kernel Patch gegen Freebase Day 11, der das reinhaut. Und jetzt geht das Projekt noch weiter, das gegen den Current Head Branch sozusagen so richtig reinzuhacken. Und du kannst auch auf freebasedayfoundation.org quasi 10 Euro spenden, um dem ganzen sozusagen noch mehr Flupzidizid, Flupzidizid?
Sag's noch mal. Geh mit zum ITF-Meeting und verteil ihn da. Sag, ihr klickt jetzt mal 10 Euro an, dass es aus dem Diff kommt.
Flupzidizid.
Und schon haben wir noch einen Sendungs-DiZidid.
Du kannst jetzt nicht explizit zu diesem Projekt spenden, aber die FreebaseDayFoundation wird sicherlich die Gelder richtig verteilen. Da ist der Link. Das ist auch immer ganz interessant zu sehen bei der FreebaseDayFoundation, wer da die letzten Jahre die Major Donators waren, die sozusagen FreebaseDay... Google ist auch immer ganz viel dabei.
Apfel nicht, komischerweise.
WhatsApp war auf jeden Fall, gehen wir mal bei Donors.
Der hat ja erst eine Million gespendet vor, als er gekauft wurde von Facebook.
Der WhatsApp-Typ.
Intel ist jetzt im aktuellen Run der Top-Donor.
Silver. Gold gibt's gar nicht.
Microsoft und VMware.
Die finden den V-Hive ganz teuer. Oder so.
Muss man bei 2016 gucken, weil dieses Jahr ist ja noch nicht so lang. Und gegen Ende des Jahres, wenn so die Gelder nochmal abgeschrieben werden müssen, dann kommen dann immer noch mal so einige Brocken dazu.
Dirk Mekjusik ist der Schreiber von dem FreeBSD im UFS.
Der spendet selber auch noch.
Der spendet selber auch noch. Der hat auch das FreeBSD Buch mitgeschrieben.
Irgendwo hab ich mal Hans Hübner in einem Jahr so auch. Also ich weiß nicht, war jetzt keine ganz große Spende, aber es war auf jeden Fall einer der, die noch mit Namen genannt werden. Klingt mal oben auf 2016.
Du meinst, da ist er dabei?
Nee, ich glaub, er war, also ich hab ihn glaube ich 2015 gesehen, aber hier da ist dieses Tab. Ist auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen her. da gibt's gar keinen.
Man kann suchen.
Juniper, Facebook ist auch dabei, Netflix, Arm.
Da gibt's ein Uranium Anonymous Donor.
Genau, aber auf jeden Fall, wenn auch ihr euren Beitrag für Multiparty CP. Fluktizität, genau. Das ist der Stand von Multiparty CP.
Jetzt aber Hardware, ne?
Ich hab vorhin noch was. Geht auch schnell.
Das hast du vorhin auch gesagt.
Wir treten jetzt in die letzten 64 Minuten einen, den Roaming in Europa noch was kostet. Das heißt, nach Ende der Sendung könnt ihr Roamen, bis der Arzt kommt. Nein, nicht bis der Arzt kommt. Nein, nein, nein. Aber um.
Ob die Krankenversicherung Roaming anbietet, muss man vorher erklären.
Clemens, das ist der 15. Juni. Welche Zeit? 0 Uhr? UTC oder Deutsche Zeit?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Dass die Leute eine Stunde zu früh loslegen.
Ist ja immer die Frage, ob das denn auch für das Heimnetz oder das Besuch der Netz gilt.
Das ist bestimmt Paris Zeit.
Also liebe Hörer, nicht einfach jetzt sofort los roamen. Erst wenn ihr die Sendung wirklich runtergeladen habt.
Also in vier Minuten und dann können langsam mal Leute in Bulgarien anfangen, das zu probieren.
Wenn ihr die Sendung runtergeladen habt, ist gut. Erst dann, dann verhören sie deinen Hinweis.
Ja, dann ist es für die nächste Sendung noch relevant.
Hardware. Es gibt iMacs.
Ja, dann sprich mal.
Aber ein Feature da war schon interessant, mindestens. Und zwar, ich glaube, mit diesem 10-Bit-Farbraum, das ist neu, oder?
Ich meine ja, dass der letzte iMac, der 5K-iMac das eigentlich auch schon irgendwie gehabt hat.
10-Bit-Farben?
Na, was denn sonst? 8-Bit gibt es ja nun schon seit 30 Jahren.
Ja eben, deswegen. Ich glaube, der hatte nur diese 5K. Das war das Besondere. 10-Bit hatte der, glaube ich, noch nicht.
Doch, da bin ich mir sogar relativ sicher, dass 10-Bit dazu Sprache kam.
Also die iPads hatten 10-Bit schon, die iPad Pros.
Ja, und meiner Meinung nach auch der 5K iMac.
Mac-Tracker.
Und jetzt haben sie das wohl dann auch über alle iMacs hinweg. Warum sie das nochmal explizit so erwähnt haben, habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden. Weil, wie gesagt, für mich war das jetzt keine News.
Deswegen haben wir so Leute für mich reinzulegen, die sich nicht mehr erinnern können, dass es eigentlich nichts Neues ist.
Kann schon sein.
Wir fallen ja da immer wieder drauf rein.
Wobei es war von 10-Bit dithering die Rede.
Also der von 2015, der 5K Mac Pro, oder der Late 2015? Ah, Late 2015, okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob so ein Detail da überhaupt steht im Mac Tracker.
Ja, wenn... Wo, wenn nicht im Mac Tracker, oder?
Ja, im Chat meint jemand, er hätte 10-Bit im 2015er iMac 5K.
Also da steht auf jeden Fall White Color Gamut.
Das ist auch das im Wesentlichen. Ja, hier Pixel Devs, 30-Bit Color, also bei RGB halt 10-10-10. Also, wie gesagt, das ist mir unklar, warum sie das jetzt gemeldet haben nochmal, aber vermutlich weil es sich auf die komplette Reihe bezieht, dann halt wohl auch auf den 4K iMac und so weiter. Und vorher war es nur der 5K iMac, warum auch immer. Na ja, dann haben sie wohl GPU-mäßig ganz ordentlich dazu geladen, ansonsten hat sich nicht so richtig viel getan.
Na ja, Kabilake.
Preis noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen schneller.
Aber die haben noch die gleiche Strukturbreite, werden also jetzt nicht megamäßig viel weniger Strom verbrauchen. Es wird so spannend.
Keine reinen HD, außer dem allerkleinsten.
Diese Helligkeitseinheit Nits, die kam das erste Mal vor, oder? Hat die jemand schon mal nachgegoogelt?
Das ist aber die Standard-Einheit, glaube ich.
Die hab ich noch nie vorher gehört gehabt.
Nee, da haben sie auch schon in den letzten beiden Präsentationen schon kräftig mit rumgewurstelt und Nits haben sie wohl eine ganze Menge mehr dazu. Also die Displays sind halt noch heller. Wobei Helligkeit irgendwie meiner Meinung nach gar nicht so richtig das Problem ist.
Also Kontrast wäre interessant, ne?
Ja, also ich meine...
Die SI-Einheit, der leuchtet, ist Candela pro Quadratmeter im englischsprachigen Raum. Vor allem in den USA wird dafür auch die Bezeichnung NIT verwendet. Das ist ein NIT, das ist gleich ein Candela pro Quadratmeter.
Ami ist wieder. Immerhin ist es das gleiche und nicht irgendwie Füße pro Quer-Bahnheit.
Ein Kerzenschein pro Quadratmeter ist auch irgendwie krass.
Irgendwo musst du deine Referenzen setzen.
Die sind halt irgendwie heller geworden und sind irgendwie toller geworden und sind dann insgesamt bei den Feature Sets ein bisschen billiger geworden. Besonders das 4K-Modell gibt es glaube ich schon ab 1.3, aber für mich wäre so ein kleiner Bild schon irgendwie nichts. Und ansonsten haben sie halt fettere 3D-Karten drin.
Aber man kann sie immer noch nicht als externen Monitor benutzen, ne?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das ging halt lange Zeit nicht. Und ich fände das auch mal schön, weil das wäre für mich das Signal, dass ich mal wieder upgraden kann. Weil mein 2009er iMac kann das und ich benutze das. Und wenn ich das mit einem neuen iMac nicht kann, dann kauf ich den nicht, Apple. Penner.
Deswegen ist für mich so ein iMac auch irgendwie nicht in der Diskussion. Überhaupt nicht.
Null. Ja, so viel dazu. Aber dann kam ja The Big News, iMac Pro. Ich war so ein bisschen überrascht, dass sie den schon angekündigt haben. Aber das war wahrscheinlich eine Folge.
Aus der Not heraus.
Also hätten sie es nicht gebracht, dann wären wieder alle unruhig geworden. Und dann haben sie es halt einfach mal angekündigt. Und jetzt gibt es halt den iMac demnächst. Also Dezember, glaube ich, ne? Mit LCC-Ramen wie ein Mac Pro. Mit irgendwie fetten Xeon-Prozessoren wie ein Mac Pro. Mit bis zu 18-Core, aber wahrscheinlich ist das unbezahlbar.
Das ist halt die CPU. Die haben halt den Sockel, den sie nutzen, und machen dann halt von Intel rein, was Intel so anbietet. Und das ist halt 18-Cores. Das kannst du aber wirklich nicht bezahlen, weil so eine CPU alleine kostet irgendwie 3000 Dollar oder 18-Core, keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch 6000 Dollar.
6000 Dollar in 18-Core?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ich guck mal.
Ist halt ne Menge Core.
Ist ne Menge Core, kostet ne Menge Kohle.
Ach so, bei Intel stehen natürlich keine Preise. 3400 Dollar bei Amazon. Ich weiß aber jetzt nicht, was das hier für ein Angebot ist, aber nur mal so als ungefähre Preisklasse.
Ich fand aber die Attitüde ganz gut, mit der sie das so vorgestellt haben. Die sind, ach, wir haben jetzt keinen Bock, immer nur so, jetzt gucken wir einfach mal, was geht. So, jetzt mal, zack. Wir machen doch mal ein 10G, ist ja net dran. So, flop. Und so finde ich jetzt einfach mal.
Man hat das Gefühl, dass sie von dieser Welle der Empörung a la Apple baut ja eigentlich keine ordentlichen Macs mehr. Das ist alles nur Spielzeug und das ist alles scheiße. Und das hat keine Zukunft mehr. Und die wollen ja eigentlich nur noch iPhones verkaufen. Ich glaube, dass sie davon ein bisschen geschockt waren.
Das hat die total deprimiert, ja.
Und dass dieser PC, dieser Mac Pro Roundtable, das war doch auch garantiert so eine Hoppla-Hop-Ding. Naja, es wurde immer spekuliert, dass sie schon ein Jahr an diese Mac Pro basteln und so weiter. Das ist, glaube ich, kein Wort daran.
Was wurde da spekuliert? Gesagt haben sie das nicht?
Nee, gesagt haben sie es nicht. Aber es haben halt viele spekuliert, dass sie den Roundtable machen, weil sie halt schon eine Weile an dem Gerät bauen und das jetzt aber fanden, dass sie das jetzt mal sagen sollen. Aber für mich wirkte das so, als hätten sie jetzt hektisch der Welt da draußen sagen müssen, nein, nein, doch, doch, wir machen noch Pro.
Na ja, sicher. Natürlich. Warum sollten sie es sonst machen? Also ich meine, sonst machen sie nie sowas.
Und in dem Thema ist natürlich auch, dass sie den Mac Pro jetzt ankündigen, obwohl es ihn erst in einem halben Jahr gibt.
Nee, sie haben den Mac Pro noch gar nicht angekündigt.
Den Mac Pro. Den Mac Pro ankündigen, obwohl sie ihn erst im Dezember oder was das war, ausliefern wollen. Das spielt ja eigentlich, haut ja in die gleiche Kerbe. Also die versuchen jetzt, die Abwanderung von diversen Leuten zu verhindern.
Und sie haben auch gleich erkannt, was die Pro-Farbe ist.
Grau. Dunkel. Ja, das finde ich auch cool. Die Tastatur gibt es auch in Dunkel.
Das ist aber auch die mit dem kurzen Hub, ne?
Wahrscheinlich.
Pro-Tastatur, wo die Cursor-Tasten so dicht sind, könnt ihr voll verlieren.
Hat das T in großen Tasten, aber es ist halt die mit dem kurzen Hub, die wahrscheinlich auch relativ laut klappert. Das ist halt nicht Pro.
Die Cursor-M klappert noch viel lauter, das ist schon ziemlich Pro, aber dieser kurze Hub ist nicht Pro.
Vor allem dieses komische Klick. Vor allen Dingen, wenn die Tastatur nach einem halben Jahr schon versagt einfach. Also vor allem nicht mal hartem Hacken, sondern so weichgespültes Hipster-Hacken. Geht auch schon kaputt. Von der kleinsten Hautschuppe.
Das ist wirklich peinlich.
Also könnt ihr euch erinnern, wann es das letzte Mal mit einer Mac-Tastatur Probleme gab?
Also nicht im ersten halben Jahr.
Na, nicht im ersten halben Jahr.
Dass eine Tastatur irgendwann auf ist, ist irgendwie nach ein paar Jahren.
Die letzte Tastatur, die bei mir physikalischen Schaden genommen hat.
War eine MacBook Pro-Tastatur definitiv. Und zwar, das war das früheste Erinnerungs-Titanium, wenn du irgendwann mal so ein Nipsey von der Wippe...
Genau, beim Titanium hatte ich das, genau.
Nee, das hatte ich nie. Hab ich bei anderen Leuten gesehen, aber hatte ich selber nicht.
Das war so ein bisschen flaky. Da brachen diese Plasteschnupsis ein bisschen leicht raus. Und bei diesem Lombard war das auch noch das Problem. Also diese Powerbook G4-Generation. Danach war das Problem weg.
Ja, also ich kann mich dann auch nicht mehr erinnern, dass ich dann nochmal irgendwas kaputtes hatte.
Eine kaputte Tastatur... Gut, es mag Leute geben, bei denen die Tastatur kaputtgegangen ist. Das ist nicht das, was ich behaupten will, dass die nie kaputt gehen. Nur aus so eigenem evidenzbasierten Wahrnehm von mir und meinem Freundeskreis kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass das ein Problem ist. Und jetzt klagen alle darüber.
Also ich nenne ja meine Computer, also ich nummeriere die ja durch, also ausgeschriebene Zahlen, damit ich sozusagen immer weiß, der wievielte Mac ist das jetzt, den ich gerade habe.
Ach, wie viel heißt denn deiner jetzt?
Meine haben nur Anfangsbuchstaben, die durchlaufen.
Das ist dein dreizehntes Mac?
Aber mit Desktop und alles, was du früher hast.
Mit allem, mit allen.
Das ist ja mal ein guter Namespace.
Ja, das ist ganz einfach. Und vor allem das geile ist, ich hab zuhause jetzt drei Computer. Mein altes MacBook Pro, mein MacBook Pro unter dem Tisch und das neue MacBook Pro. Und wenn ich die im Netzwerk alle sehe, weiß ich halt genau, ahja, Eleven ist halt die alte...
Das ist einfach cool. Ich überleg nur gerade, wo ich jetzt wäre, hätt ich dasselbe Schema.
Ich bin bei K, das ist 11.
Sind das nur deine Computer oder deine Macs?
Nur die Macs.
Hast du jetzt 13 Geräte durch?
Ja, ich hab ja bei der Arbeit von Arbeitgeber Geräte, die zähl ich dann halt mit, weil ich sie ja auch privat nutze und so.
Die hab ich nie mitgezählt.
Also ich benutze ja, ich hab ja keine reinen Firmenrechner jeweils gehabt und ich würde mich auch versuchen dagegen zu werden, dass ich benutze halt auch Firmenrechner. Auf jeden Fall, genau, wenn ich dann so durchgehe von diesen 13 Macs, bei welchen hatte ich Tastaturprobleme? Ich kann mich nur erinnern, das Titanium, da ist da die Nipsis unter den Wippen mal irgendwann weggeknuspert und dann hingen mir die Tasten auf halb acht, aber ansonsten...
Nein, ich hatte nie Tastaturprobleme. Nee, ich hab die, ich benenne die immer, also die Anfangsbuchstaben laufen halt durch. Also, aber ich hab halt auch nicht Macs mitgezählt, einige wenige, muss man dazu sagen. Ah, zum Beispiel war der Amiga. Also er hatte keinen gesonderten Namen, aber der bekam dann das A.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Allerdings war das dann auch schon der Zweite, aber trotzdem.
Was ist so dein favorisiertes Naming-Schema, Clemens, für deine Privatcomputer?
Sehr schwer, immer wieder sehr schwer.
Also hast du keinen Schema?
Ja, ab und zu, wenn ich so, ich mach mir mal dann Schema auf, wenn ich mal mehrere Sachen mach, weißt du, Cluster-Bau oder sowas.
Aber deine eigenen Rechner, die heißen...
Meine eigenen Rechner heißen irgendwie MBP, Macbook Pro, so. Weil die hab ich auch in der Regel nicht mehrere davon, die ich gleichzeitig einrichte. Also wie gesagt, auf Server ist das eher mal was, oder so Router, oder so. Router werden namlos durchnummeriert oder mit Locations versehen, oder sowas. Das ist eher boring.
Ich hab irgendwann mal bei, ich glaub bei Seven hab ich angefangen. Erstens weil mir in dem Moment kein Name einfiel, der irgendwie Sinn macht. Und zweitens dachte ich mir, ich will irgendwie das Wissen sozusagen, wie viel das ist. Oder irgendwie aus einem komischen Spleen raus. Und jetzt so, ja, einige 6 MacBooks oder Geräte später, ist es irgendwie ganz geil zu wissen. Ich hatte jetzt 13.
Ja, also ich hab immer lateinische Begriffe gehabt bisher. Also dieser hier heißt jetzt Corianis Casius, ist der erste, der keinen lateinischen Namen hat. Das ist halt Hobby jetzt, aber...
Damit man es leichter hintippt.
Ich tippe das nie ein.
Richtig, das tippst du auch nie ein.
Und der nächste heißt dann Cronos oder Baraka? Oder wie war das?
Warte ich noch, mich immer noch gut dran erinnert, Tim, das ist auch was wieder für dich, wenn wir wieder so die alte Männer Podcast machen und in der Vergangenheit schwelgen. Ich fand das gut, die bei Art & Com diese Dinge mit den Kaufläden. Und je teurer, je fetter die Maschine war, desto teurer war der Kauflein. Ich weiß noch, gab ne Maschine, die hieß KDW, das war so das große, fette, teure Ding. Aldi und Lidl gab es so als Workstations oder so.
Die ganz fette war die Herte.
Die ganz fette war Herte?
Herte, fett. Die SGI, die Onyx, das war die Herte.
War das nicht KDW?
Nee, KDW war... was anderes. Ich weiß aber grad nicht mehr genau, was die KDW war.
Fand ich irgendwie witzig, da kann man ein bisschen was mitmachen.
War der geilste Namespace, ich weiß... aber warte mal, hat mir die nicht auch parat kommen? Oder war das ein CCC-Namespace? Nee, das war parat kommen. Und zwar Städte, in denen Katastrophen passiert ist. Also als halt nur so Bopal, CW, Tschernobyl und so.
Bei uns in der Firma hab ich mal irgendwann sämtliche Appledivices benannt. Und hab dann die große Liste der Apfelsortennamen aufgerufen.
Hatte aber auch schon mal Boscoop und so.
Genau, und dann haben die aber je nachdem, ob das jetzt ein 4 oder ein 5, 5S und so weiter, gab's halt immer neuen Anfangsbuchstaben, weil da waren so viele Sorten drin irgendwie.
Und der beknackteste Namespace, also nicht beknackt, also eigentlich der größte, war eine ODK bisher, das sind nämlich Schriftnamen und es gibt einfach eine unendliche Anzahl von Schriftnamen. Jedes Wort, was es in der Sprache gibt, gibt es auch Schriftnamen, das heißt, du kannst im Prinzip alles aussuchen.
Das war dann wiederum nicht so gut.
Also wir haben mal im Team mal für eine größere Location, wo wir Access verteilt haben, auf mehrere Hallen. Da haben wir auch ein Naming Scheme gemacht. Damals gab es da noch getrennte Access Points für 5 Gigahertz und für 2,4. Die 5 Gigahertz hatten alle weibliche Namen, für 2,4 alle männliche Namen. Der erste Buchstabe war immer sozusagen, die reinfolgende Alphabet war die Hallennummer, das heißt, alle Access Points in Halle 1 fingen mit A an, eben entsprechend weiblich-männlich nach Typ. Und dann der Kollege Wetterfrosch, der das auch da gemacht hat, der hatte dann noch weiter nicht mehr gesagt, der erste Vokal in dem Namen sagt dir an, in welcher Himmelsrichtung, also in welcher Ecke diese Ding hängt. Das heißt, du konntest sagen, also irgendwie... Ja, der erste...
Aber wie war das gemapt?
Also wenn der erste Vokal ein A ist, ist das Ding in der Nordseite der Halle. Wenn der zweite ein E ist, oder der erste Vokal ein E ist in dem Namen, dann und so weiter und so fort. Das ist das Oste. Er hat ewig da in irgendwelchen Namenslisten aus dem Internet gezogen und kam auf die abstrusesten Namen für diese Exist-Polizei. Aber das hat sich lange Zeit gehalten, weil man konnte halt einfach dem Namen ansehen, wusste es genau, wo der steckt. Du hast einfach irgendeinen Namen gelesen, wusste es ja, den finde ich in der Halle und da in dieser Ecke da hinten. Das fand ich schon ganz cool. Dann haben wir das noch weiter getrieben, irgendwelche Switches waren irgendwelche Bäume. Und die Route hatten keinen speziellen Namen, aber Switches. Oder irgendwelche anderen Pflanzen. Er hat die obskursten Pflanzen aufgetrieben aus diesen diversen Internet-Verzeichnissen. Bis zu dem Punkt hin, dass er jetzt irgendwelche Pflanzen, die keine Sau kannte und wo niemand wusste, wie man die schreibt, was dann echt scheiße war. Dann hast du ihn gefragt, was ist mit dem Switch? Ja, log sich einfach drauf ein. Ja, wie? Ja, sagst du SSH, hm, und keiner wusste, wie man hm schreibt. Da musstest du erst mal nach googeln, wie diese komische Mulanze hieß. Aber das kann man halt eben auch machen, dass man so Generierte-Namespaces sozusagen nimmt. Das finde ich Katastrophen, hatte zwei Vorteile.
Erstens, du kriegst am laufenden Meter neue, weil diese Katastrophen bleiben ja nicht aus. Und zweitens haben die so einen hohen Wiedererkennungswert, weil die einmal durch die News gespült werden, dass du weißt, wie man das schreibt. Also so Bopal weiß halt jeder, dass das so wie BH, OP, AL, ist so, ne? Nur bei Chernobyl ist es natürlich so ein bisschen schwierig so mit den...
Da gibt es verschiedene Schreibweisen mit der Transkription.
Transliteration oder wie das heißt, ne? Ich hab jetzt mal gezählt, ich bin bin grad so bei 10. Ich glaube, es waren so 10. Wobei da meine Artplus-Com-Phase auch kontraproduktiv war, weil die hat irgendwie...
Wie kann das denn ein 10 sein? Hier stehen noch alleine 4.
Ne, das ist ja eigentlich nur eine Glotze. Dann hat er sein R.
Also mein erster...
Mein erster Mac war ein 2Ci. Der hatte ich relativ lange. Und den hatte ich halt, bis ich bei Artcom kram und Artcom hat halt irgendwie gefühlt jeden Monat irgendwie neue Computer gekauft. Das heißt, ich hatte so einen riesigen Park und dann war ich auch noch der Admin dafür. Ich hatte so viele Macs aller Art, dass ich...
Oder genutzte Macs?
Ich hatte kein Privatleben. Wir haben ja da mehr oder weniger gewohnt. Und Laptops waren ja so noch nicht erschwinglich. Dann kamen so die ersten Powerbooks raus, aber das war irgendwie noch nix. Und der erste portable Mac, den ich mir gekauft habe, war Powerbook 3400C fette Teil mit dem Subwoofer.
Das muss doch mehr als zehn sein. Du hattest doch ein Titanium mindestens.
Das kam mir danach. Du hattest Powerbook G3, dann hattest du das Titanium G4, dann hattest du ein MacBook, das schwarze.
So.
Also, wir haben jetzt CI, erster Laptop, dritter Laptop. So, wir sind bei vier. Dann hatte.
Ich irgendwann einen...
Da hatte ich noch einen Powerbook G4. Ich glaube, ich hatte noch einen Powerbook G4. Und dann hatte ich einen... Ich hatte auch, glaube ich, mal so einen MacBook Pro. Kann ich mich irgendwie nur noch schämenhaft daran erinnern? Weil dann kam irgendwann das R. Und das ist ja der geilste Computer, den ich je hatte. Der geilste Computer, den Apple je gebaut hat, bis heute. Und davon habe ich jetzt den zweiten.
Also portablen Computer, ne?
Bin ich jetzt bei sieben. Ja, so meine Primärcomputer. Und dann hatte ich noch einen iMac, dann hatte ich mal einen Mac Mini, der wurde mir geklaut, zehn, meinen Mac Pro und den iMac hier.
12.
Dann will ich auch.
Was willst du auch? Aufzählen.
Also ich würde mal sagen, der erste war der virtuelle, nämlich Shapeshifter auf einem Amiga. Aber es war mein erster Mac.
Das ist die Null Nummer, mein Freund.
Das ist die Null. Aber damit ging es halt los. Das war der Grund, warum ich mir dann einen Mac gekauft habe. Dann habe ich mir halt den PowerPC 7500 geholt.
Kein 60k Mac.
Ich auch nicht.
Also später kamen die noch.
Wenn man den Amiga nicht mitzählt, nein.
Also PowerPC 7500, dann hatte ich noch einen Quadra 700, einen Quadra 840 AV. Dann habe ich mir mal einen Pismo geholt.
Das habe ich übersprungen.
Dann hatte ich glaube ich auch von Arbeit, weil ihr habt ja der Arbeitsrechner mitgezählt, hatte ich auch so einen 3400 dafür eine Weile mal. Das waren jetzt fünf. Dann kam das Titanium.
Das 3400, da war ja vor dem Pismo.
Ja, das kann sein. Die Reihenfolge weiß ich nicht so genau. Dann kam jedenfalls ein Titanium hatte ich. Dann habe ich mir wann war ein Titanium? 2003, 2004, so in dem Drehjahr.
Fragen wir den Mac-Tracker.
2002, so das passt. Jedenfalls habe ich mir 2006 dann das erste Intel geholt. Das wurde dann, sagen wir mal, konfessiert. Dann habe ich mir 2006 noch Neues geholt, also ein Modell später. Das hat dann bis 2011 gehalten und dann habe ich mir das erste Quadcore geholt. Und dann habe ich mir jetzt letztes Jahr das aktuelle MacBook Pro geholt. Das sind jetzt zehn. Und dann habe ich noch einen Dual-500. Wie hieß das Dual-Core? Dieser Mac Pro? Nee, wie hieß das Ding? Nee, das war schon Power PC Dual-500. Wie hießen die Dinger? Keine Ahnung. Dual-Core 500. Das ist noch Nummer 11. Dieser Lutsch-Bombon-Rechner, wisst ihr schon. Und dann noch meinen Mac Pro, den ich habe.
Was ist denn mit dem X2, von dem du neulich erzählt hast?
Ich hab jetzt noch einen X2 zu Hause rumstehen, das ist dann Nummer 13. Was heißt?
Gleich viel. Du hast den High-Five verpasst.
Ich glaube, ich komme nicht auf die Nummer, weil ich mein Zeug zu länger... Ich behalte es so lange, wie es läuft. Und es läuft einfach viel zu lange. Mein Mac Pro, was ich hier gerade vor mir habe, ist über sieben Jahre alt. Er spielt immer noch super, ist immer noch flüssig.
Ich hab ja noch meinen iMac zuhause.
Ich hatte das erste.
Ich hab nämlich auch...
Ich hätte mal drei iMacs zuhause.
Ich hab letztens auch wieder gedacht, 13 stimmt das? Hab ich nicht doch irgendwie einen PC mitgezählt? Aber man vergisst dann halt auch noch so ein paar Sachen. Ich hab ja auch noch hier so einen Cube... So einen Cube aus der Uni abgestaubt. Der steht auch noch rum.
In meiner Rechnung sind... Da ist... Da ist ein PC dabei. Und ein Amiga. Allerdings keiner von den Firmenrechnern. Und das würde ich auch nicht mehr zusammenkriegen. Das ist mindestens ein halbes Dutzend.
Ich zähl halt jeden Rechner, wo ich selber den Hostnamen setze, sozusagen.
Ja, aber ich hatte... Für die Arbeit hatte ich immer ein anderes Naming-Schirm.
Wie viele PCs hattest du?
Maximal zwei.
Ab wann gilt denn ein PC?
Oder drei?
Wenn er Gehäuse hat?
Das Ding ist halt... Ich hatte glaube ich zwei... Nee, ich hatte zwei PC-Gehäuse. Nee, ich sag mal zwei. Ich hatte erst einen so Billo Tower und dann hab ich mir später noch mal so eine Gaming-Buchse zusammengeschraubt. Aber es waren zwei maximal.
Also ich hab irgendwann mal einen XT, einen Olivetti XT mit 8 Mhz abgestaubt, wo glaube ich so ein DOS 3.3 oder so drauf lief. Dann irgendwie, also immer so alte, ausrangierte Rechner hatte ich relativ viele PCs. Dann hab ich tatsächlich irgendwann mal einen Gaming-PC gekauft. Und dann wurde es mit der PC-Seite schon ein bisschen... So jetzt ist der eine Mac, auf dem irgendwie ein Bootcamp drauf ist, zählt der mit? Nee, das ist kein PC. Und jetzt hab ich den kleinen PC wieder. Zählt ein Raspberry Pi, wo man mal ein Windows 10 drauf gemacht hat.
Nein, Arbeitsrechner, komm her. Ein Ding, was du wirklich benutzt hast. Jetzt fang ich nicht so kleinkariert an. Das ist doch keine Schande, wenn du wenig PCs hattest. Sei doch froh.
Arbeitsrechner hab ich, also die Dinger, die halt auf Arbeit standen, aber die würde ich jetzt sowieso nicht mehr zusammenkriegen.
So ein Rechner, den du besessen hast, auf dem du was gewuppt hast, außer vielleicht den Hostname vergeben hast. Und dem du deinen Hostname aufgedrückt hast.
Na gut, bei dem Olivetti gab es noch keine Hostnamen. Keine Ahnung, es wären vielleicht drei oder vier gewesen sein. Mehr waren es nicht.
Wollen wir nicht einfach mit Hardware weitermachen?
Ja, bitte.
Aber mir fällt ein, ich hatte tatsächlich einen 68K Mac, diesen Performer 475.
Siehst du, da kommen sie alle aus den Löchern gekrabbelt.
Fürchterliches Ding, aber wer tat? War mein Einstieg zum Mac.
Gut, abdem wir jetzt die alte Herrenabteilung durch haben.
Wer hat jetzt weniger PCs gehabt?
Alter, ich hab weniger PCs gehabt als du.
Alter.
Alterlahn.
Next. Haben wir noch was? Haben wir noch Themen? Hardware. War da noch was?
Ja, was sie noch vorgestellt haben, was wir interessant finden.
War noch irgendwas? Punkt 6.
Ich fang mal an. Und zwar haben sie vorgestellt, ich glaub, da gibt es auch einen Developer-Krit, richtig? Und zwar für ein externer GPU, also so ein externes Gehäuse, was man mit Thunderbolt 3 anschließt, wo halt ein PCI-Extreme-Slot drin ist, wo man halt eine Grafikkarte reinstecken kann. Und weil das so ist, ist auch in Highsy Era sind jetzt Grafiktreiber drin, die halt vorher nicht so da waren für bestimmte Geräte, ID's, das heißt eine RX 480 von AMD, die vorher nicht funktioniert hätte, wenn man sie reingesteckt hätte, ohne weiteres Rumgepatche. Die sollte jetzt einfach funktionieren.
Wenn man einen Mac hat, wo man noch Grafikkarten reinstecken kann.
Genau, zum Beispiel im Classic Mac Pro.
Die im einzigen Mac sehr relevant ist.
Jetzt wollte ich mal gucken, wie kommt man an dieses Grafik, dieses Kit?
Ja, nur als Developer.
Ja, bin ich ja. Daran liegt es nicht.
Wie viel, was sollt ihr haben, 600 Dollar oder so? Nur für den Kasten, ohne die Karte, richtig?
Nee, die Karte ist da drin, aber es ist keine besonders gute. Also zumindest ist sie von AMD.
Ja, aber dass sie jetzt die Grafiktreiber aufmachen, das ist eine gute Sache. Das hilft wirklich den Leuten, die noch Mac Pro haben und dann mal ein bisschen was Fettes reinstecken wollen.
Die haben sehr zwischenzeitlich allerdings.
Sie haben sich verirrt, irgendwas, irgendeinen Grund. Ja, und jetzt noch die Killer-Hate, oder? Nein, das, was unser Living Room revolutionieren wird, unsere gesamte Music Experience revolutionieren wird.
Das war so ein bisschen der Donner, ne?
Auf den deutschen Marken nicht unbedingt abgestimmt, aber hey.
Aber das Gerät ist auch nicht so der Donner.
Vor allen Dingen sieht es aus wie so eine Klorollenbehäkelung auf einem Mac.
Die Mac Pros, die sie nicht verkaufen konnten, die stecken da drin wahrscheinlich.
Das Hekelkleid für Mac Pro, oh mein, ich brich ab.
Ja, aber so sieht es doch aus. Oder wie so ein Kratzbaum für Mac-affine Katzen. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Kratzenbaum hab ich auch schon gehört.
Und ich bin mir ja überhaupt nicht sicher, dass das Ding auch so toll klingt, wie es angeblich klingt.
Das ist der Hekeltosch. Gibt es jetzt auch einen Selbstgestrick?
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Also mein Inneres hat ja nach so was jetzt nicht unbedingt geschrien.
Tut es auch jetzt noch nicht.
Wobei, ich hab jetzt auch nichts gegen einen Lautsprecher, der ordentlichen Sound macht und mobil ist. Und so, hat der Akku? Oder muss man den an Strom anschließen?
Der hat ziemlich sicher Strom.
Der ist dafür zu Hause. Steht auch da auch drum, damit Siri dir lauschen kann. Der wäre so, komm mal, nix leer.
Hast du gesehen, was die da für eine Spule eingebaut haben? Das Teil hat ja kein Gehäuse. Wo soll denn der umherkommen? Das Ding verbraucht garantiert einiges an Strom. Weil der da ganz schön Membran schiebt, um so ein bisschen Sound zu machen.
Okay.
Also davon kannst du mal ausgehen.
Also ist das nix für einen Wohnwagen?
Eher nicht. Also ich mag mich täuschen. Kann man den schon klicken?
Also ob der 220 Volt sieht, das bezweifle ich jetzt auch mal. Der hat bestimmt nur ein Netzteil.
Ja, der hat ein Netzteil drin, aber der braucht so viel Strom.
Gute Frage.
Will ich eine Boxi mit mir reden kann?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Ich will ja sowieso mit meinen Geräten eigentlich nicht reden, weil das ist immer so frustrierend. Ich meine, ich beklage das, glaube ich schon seit Jahren hier und hat sich irgendwas verbessert.
Was mit dem Reden?
Ja, ich meine, ich probiere das halt alle drei Monate mal wieder mit irgendwas und ich lauf schreiend davon. Also dieser ganze Siri war... Das ist der ganze Siri-Wahnsinn. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum da alle so total überdreht sind. Warum eigentlich? Die reden doch nicht die ganze Zeit mit ihren Telefonen. Machen die das?
Die machen sehr oft einen Tee und dann nutzen sie einen Teatimer. Ich kann dir sagen, was die Leute machen. Die diktieren ihre Sprachennachrichten in ihr Gerät rein.
Ja, zum Diktieren find ich das ja auch super.
Aber das ist ja schon...
Die diktieren, das war was anderes als...
Den kannst du bestimmt auch in der Nachricht diktieren.
Das ist halt so ein glorified Music Selection. Die weiß aber, ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich ihm sagen soll. Wenn ich dem sage, spiel mal geile Musik, dann hat der doch nur... Ich hab dich nicht verstanden, Tim.
Aber du spielst doch mit dem Ding nicht nur, weil du andere Musik hören willst. Die wollen natürlich, dass du darüber alles Mögliche machst.
Ja, mach die Rollos runter.
Mach Licht an, Licht aus irgendwie. Schieb ne Nachricht an, so und so raus.
Ja, dann weiß ich wieder nicht, was ich dem Ding sagen soll. Ich hab das hier schon mit dem Home-Kit, hab ich doch auch schon probiert. Da weißt du doch auch nicht, was du da sagen sollst.
Für uns ist ja sowas auch nicht.
Ich hab noch nicht genug Lichtschalter, glaube ich.
Du hast ja die ganzen Geräte dieses nicht vertragen miteinander, so dieses... Ey Siri, sag mal Alexa, sie soll...
Vielleicht hab ich auch nur Angst vor dem Rise of the Machines. Ich möcht's gar nicht herausfordern. Ich möcht gar nicht wissen, dass die schon so intelligent sind, dass sie hinter uns konspirieren.
Also da steht was von Dezember, ich glaub...
Lassen wir mal den Siri-Quatsch mal weg. Das Ding ist irgendwie ein 350-Dollar-Lautsprecher und der macht halt irgendwie so akustisches Beamforming, indem er die Reflexionen misst mit seinen Mikrofonen, die die Lautsprecher machen. Soweit ich weiß, macht Sonos sowas aber auch. Also das ist jetzt nicht neu, oder?
Neu ist wahrscheinlich nicht, aber...
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber...
Aber im Endeffekt haben sie dem ganzen Ding noch einen A8-Professor reingestöpselt. Das ist ja schon mal für so einen Lautsprecher auch ordentlich.
Weniger können sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr reinmachen, weil weniger bauen sie gar nicht mehr. Das ist schon so das kleinste, was sie derzeit bauen. Und so ein bisschen Processing brauchen sie dann natürlich auch, wenn das Ding halt wirklich so ein Home-Kit-Hub ist, was ja durchaus sinnvoll ist, weil nicht jeder hat Apple TV, aber vielleicht so einen Lautsprecher.
Das ist natürlich praktisch dann.
Aber ich meine, wie kriegst du da was hingesetzt, wenn man das Ding ist doch bestimmt kein Bluetooth-Lautsprecher? Der macht doch nur Airplay.
Airplay 2 heißt es hier.
Ja, gut, aber wenn ich jetzt ein Device hab, was kein Airplay 2 hat, das hat wahrscheinlich auch keinen...
Nein, der Lautsprecher ist das Device. Der Lautsprecher spielt. Du sagst ihm doch, was er abspielen soll. Und dann guckt er bei Apple nach.
Ja, was heißt ich sagen?
Und findet's nicht und spielt Hino.
Oder so.
Here's some Helene Fischer for you.
Datenlos durch die Nacht.
Du kennst sogar noch ein Lieder von der, oder was?
Das ehrte ich jetzt, Huckel, dass du das nicht kennst.
Ich kenn 0,0 Helene Fischer.
Noch nicht mal das?
Oh, das ist gut. Das ist wirklich gut.
Also ich weiß, dass das Lied existiert, aber kenn ich es auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Mir hat das bei mir gerade überhaupt keine Mustererkennung.
Das Huckel-Learning hat nicht trainiert.
Ja, meine einzige Ausrede ist auch nur, dass irgendwie die Kinder das vorträllern. Kann man sich dem nicht erzielen.
Deine Kinder hören Helene Fischer.
Diese Welt da draußen.
Du lässt deine Kinder in die Welt raus?
Natürlich.
Muss man wohl. Bringen die aus dem Kindergarten mit diesen Krankheiten, ne?
Ja, und dann schalten sie manchmal im Fernseher Sachen ein.
Auf der Apple-Webseite zeigen sie das Ding aus Perspektiven, wo man nicht sieht, ob da jetzt ein Stromkabel dran ist oder nicht. Und bei Apple Insider haben sie jetzt so ein Vor-Ort-Bild, wo so hinten so ein richtig dickes Kabel da reingeht. Ja, ich share the link.
Zeig dir doch, wenn du dir anguckst, was für einen fetten Lautsprecher die da drin haben, dann musst du das Teil auch ordentlich satt ziehen.
Nee, mein Bode hat auch ordentlich Bums und der zieht nicht viel Saft und läuft auch mit Batterie.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, da jetzt noch einen Wurfanker dran zu machen, wäre auch echt blöd.
Da weißt du auch jetzt schon, dass das Teil nicht klingt.
Also ich würde mal behaupten, der Sound ist bestimmt ganz cool, können sich auch gar nicht anders erlauben, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich für 350 Euro das Ding kostet, ne Dollar waren das, ne? Ja, ein Lautsprecher braucht, der mir sagt, dass ich gerade die Musik nicht hören kann. Nee, ich weiß nicht. Diese ganzen Pseudo-Quatschgeräte, das ist nicht meins.
Ja, kein Klinkeneingang, kein Bluetooth.
Wasserlaube Apple.
Ja gut, dass er jetzt keinen Klinkeneingang hat, das war jetzt zu erwarten.
Bluetooth wäre schon mal eine Maßnahme gewesen.
Kein Klinkenausgang mehr, hast du brauchst keinen Klinkeneingang mehr an deinem Lautsprecher.
Ich hab mir gerade zwei iPods gekauft.
So sieht es nämlich aus.
Zwei iPods.
Na ja, auch das.
iPod Classic mit der geilsten User-Interface, die Apple kreiert hat. Clickwheel. The Clickwheel, die geil ist. Und ich würde irgendwie Geld dafür geben, wenn es für ein iPhone eine Rückwand gäbe mit Clickwheel.
Das würde ich so grandioso finden. Was machst du jetzt mit diesen iPods?
Das Gesicht von Clemens war gerade groß.
Stromsparen.
Was machst du jetzt mit deinem Telefon?
Telefon-Podcast abspielen. Tim hat halt noch seine eigene Musik, der nutzt keine Apple Music.
Ich auch nicht, ich nutze auch keine Apple Music. Ich klick halt einfach bei den iPhones in der rechts unten Modell, was den Flash angeht, da passt das alles drauf.
Die Musik, die ich gerne höre, gibt es bei Apple Music sowieso nicht.
Bei mir auch nicht.
Und deswegen kommt das überhaupt nicht in Frage.
Und auf dem iPhone ist kein Platz dafür, oder wie?
Das ist gerade meine Frage. Warum spielst du nicht auf dem iPhone? Wieso?
Klämmert es jetzt, was du sagst?
Ja, das ist jetzt zu Tim Gesicht. Warum spiel ich eigentlich Musik nicht auf dem iPhone?
Weil ich keine 160 Gigabyte auf einem iPhone habe und ich auf dem iPod einfach 160 Gigabyte Musik drauflegen kann und dieses Gerät nichts anderes tut.
Das ist die letzte Generation, die du da hast, ne?
Das ist ein iPod Classic mit 160 Gigabyte.
Weil die vorletzte Generation ist nämlich die geile, nicht die letzte.
Wieso?
Weil in der vorletzten Generation das Interface snappy ist und in der letzten Generation ist es laggy. Aus irgendeinem Grund.
Mir hat noch nicht aufgefallen. Naja, egal. Ich brauchte einfach ein Gerät, was ich an einen Lautsprecher anschließen kann und dann kommt da Musik raus.
Für lange Zeit. Aus dem Klinken-Ausgang.
Ohne Internet.
Aus dem Klinken-Ausgang.
Man nennt es Plattenspieler.
Krass, so Scheiße.
Aus dem Klinken, ja klar. Ich nehme hier so einen Sound-Würfel hier. Da bin ich gerade noch um überlegen. Wir hatten ja neulich diesen Bose Studio.
Soundlink-Mini.
Soundlink, den gibt es aber jetzt auch in der Version 3. Da weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, was man haben will. Also ich hätte irgendwie was mit Wumms. Und dann leg ich den iPod daneben und dann spielt das Ding tagelang.
Mit meinem Telefon, nur nicht tagelang.
Ja, aber dann muss ich ja mein Telefon da liegen lassen. Ich brauch doch mein Telefon für wichtige Sachen. Und mit Bluetooth, dann ist das irgendwie, ja, dann bin ich irgendwo und dann ist die Verbindung und dann reißt das ab.
Und wenn deine Kinder nervös, wenn die Hörspiele aufhören zu spielen?
Ich brauch einfach ein Abspielgerät für einen Wohnwagen. Der braucht halt einfach Musik. Und der soll da sein und Musik soll eingebaut sein. Fertig.
Du denkst nur noch in Wohnwagen.
Wenn du Wumms brauchst, also die Bluetooth-Lautsprecher von Marshall, die sind soundtechnisch ganz weit vorne, also in allen möglichen Reviews schneiden die ganz vorne mit ab und die haben Wumms.
Haben die auch Akku.
Die haben auch Akku.
Hält ja auch.
Wie war das in deinem Requirement? Hält. Wie lange?
Lange.
Ein ganzes Urlaub im Wohnwagen.
Nee, keine Ahnung. Irgendwie lädt schnell und spielt lange und muss nicht alle zwei Stunden aufgeladen werden und macht irgendwie Wumms und ist nicht zu schwer und kann man irgendwie gut hinstellen und rollt nicht vom Tisch.
Du brauchst aber dann einen 12-Volt-Laden, ne?
Nicht unbedingt, aber das...
Wäre ideal, wahrscheinlich. Ich hab den Marshall Killburn und der klingt mega geil. Allerdings kann der, glaube ich, nur Bluetooth... Also der Nachfolger ist jetzt der mit dem modernen Bluetooth, auf jeden Fall, den man dann haben will. Aber die klingen wirklich total gut. Also ich bin schwer begeistert und ich wollte halt... Die gibt es ja in Wasserfest und Spritzfest und hast du nicht gesehen. Und ich wollte aber einfach einen, den ich so hinstellen kann und macht ordentlich Sound und ich gehe damit nicht baden und so. Und will auch ein bisschen Bass und das alles. Und der ist auf jeden Fall geil. Killburn und...
Ja, und auch was so mit Bluetooth. Und funktioniert auch mit dem Bluetooth.
Und hat auch einen Klinkereingang.
Ja, das ist eh ganz wichtig.
Genau. Deswegen sag ich das ja, weil...
Und laut.
Muss auch laut.
Laut muss er sein.
Also den Wohnwagen kriegst du damit gut Bescheid. Wie gesagt, aber ich würde den...
Nicht den Wohnwagen, sondern aus dem Wohnwagen heraus.
Ja klar, das auch.
Dass man da so kleine Party davor haben kann.
Genau, ich glaub, den Nachfolge, den hab ich noch nicht getestet, aber die sehen halt auch sehr geil aus. Also die sehen wirklich schick aus, wie ich finde. Kommt jetzt sicherlich gleich noch das Bild hier im... Klick mal auf den Link, weil...
Ach so, mit Henkel zum Wegwerfen?
Nee, nee, nee. Das ist alles richtig schick verarbeitet und es kommt auch in so einem Karton, wo du den...
Ja, mit Henkel zum Wegwerfen.
Ach so, den, damit du so schleudern kannst, oder wie meinst du?
Kostet wie viel?
Ja, man kann den halt durch die Gegend tragen, das ist schon sehr praktisch. Ja, Pfund sind das, nicht Euronen.
Aber wie gesagt, es gibt jetzt ein Nachfolge-Modell, was neueres Bluetooth hat und wenn man das haben will, dann und so weiter.
Dann muss man wohl mal nach Germany changen.
Aber die sind wirklich toll verarbeitet, klingen gut. Guck mal, auf Amazon kriegst du das sogar günstiger. Kannst ja mal selber nochmal gucken, welches Modell genau der Nachfolge davon war.
Ich finde den Retro-Look ein bisschen pseudo.
Das Ding kommt auch aus der Box mit so einem Spiralklinkenkabel und die geben sich auch wirklich total Mühe, dass du so ein sehr schönes Apple-Wertigkeitsgefühl hast, wenn du das Ding da raushebst.
Für mich ist Marshall halt so ein leicht, wie soll ich sagen, so ein muffiger Probenraum.
Du, wenn du den lange genug vollquarzst und mit Bier überschüttest, dann sieht der auch so aus.
Einer von der Mit-Bands, die hatten so ein Bierdeckel im Probenraum, dann so eine Bierwerbung, dem Himmel so nah. Dann haben sie noch ein S und ein C davor gemacht, dem Schimmel so nah. Das passt halt so auf Probenraum irgendwie. Das sind immer feuchte Keller.
Tim, wenn du auf die Marshall-Webseite gehst, da gibt es dann auch die Kategorie Laut, lauter, lautest. Wenn du mehr Wumms haben willst, gibt es dann noch andere Kategorien.
Etwas, was man Marshall-Geräten normalerweise nicht vorwerfen kann, ist, dass sie zu leise sind.
Die machen ja auch Kopfhörer mittlerweile. Wenn du oben bei Speakers klickst, gibt es dann so, die alle Kategorien vorhanden will, macht Druck. Du klickst natürlich gleich rechts.
Da ist er offen etwas größer.
Na ja, wenn der stationär im Wohnwagen platziert ist, zwei Eingänge analog.
Optical Input.
Das wird aber ein Problem mit deiner zulässigen Anhängerlast. Das wartet mit deiner 1.300 kg Anhängerkupplung.
Oze hat aber kein Akku, ne?
Kein Akku außer der kleine mobile, oder? Da hat deine Akku?
Okay. Es gab aber noch so einen anderen...
Aber das ist nur laut.
Mir gefällt die Optik irgendwie auch nicht. Wenn ich die sehe, dann denke ich nicht, dass die Bluetooths können, vom Gefühl her.
Können sie aber.
Ja, aber es passt nicht zusammen.
Ist egal, wie gesagt, das ist ich.
Das ist ein bisschen sehr groß schon.
Was ist denn die Stil-Idee?
Ich kann, ja, keine Ahnung.
Stil-Idee?
Der Kilburn ist auf jeden Fall klein und portabel und hat funktioniert.
Nicht nur Bluetooth, sondern sogar Leuchteidioten.
Aber der Regler geht nur bis zehn.
Das ist aber Marshall.
Das ist Marshall, ja.
Das ist ja wohl mein, naja, ich meine.
Geht gar nicht.
Ich brauch einen, der bis elf geht.
Entschuldigung, du hast noch nie mit Marshall gearbeitet.
Nein, wie ist das mit Marshall zu arbeiten?
Wenn du bis zehn drehst, dann kannst du auch gleich zur Klinik, zum Hals, Nasen, Ohren, Ast gehen. Ja. Also so ein Marshall-Turm braucht normalerweise keinen elf.
Dann starte ich vielleicht erstmal mit laut. Aber hier steht Acton und bei dem anderen stand Killburn. Also was ist denn jetzt?
Also, ich suche dir das nochmal raus. Ich glaube nämlich, es gab einen...
Hier ist Killburn, da ist Acton, aber die sind dann nicht mehr.
Killburn ist einer von den Portable, ne?
Ach so, die sind nicht laut.
Okay, bring noch nächstes Mal einfach deinen mit, dann bring ich mal meinen Bose mit und dann machen wir mal hier Shooter. Gibt es halt jemand noch welche?
Den, schon den neueren. Gibt es jetzt einen dritten? Hast du gesehen?
Ich habe ja den kleinen. Den Dreier ist der große. Soundlink Mini gibt es keinen.
Aber ich habe Soundlink Mini 2.
Genau, aber da gibt es keinen Dreier.
Du kannst jetzt nur die Feder runterziehen.
Das Ding, was auch mit dir spricht, ne? Der auch mit dir spricht, wenn du so lauter und leiser machst.
Das ist die 200. Ihr habt eine Gala erwartet und ihr kriegt einfach nur das Schlechteste von allem. Durcheinander gequatscht. Keine klare Struktur, so sind wir.
Aber mit Liebe. Wir quatschen durcheinander.
Haben wir noch Themen.
Das ist so wie ISO 9000-Zertifizierung. Diese Qualitätssicherung in deinem Unternehmen. Das heißt nicht, dass du Qualität bist, sondern dass du konsistent die Scheiße machst, die du immer machst. Wenn du festlegst in einem Dokument, dass du jeden Kunden, der anruft, wüsst, beschimpfst und auflegst, und diese Prozedur aber dokumentiert kriegst, dann hast du eine ISO 9000-Zertifizierung.
Moment, du musst die Prozedur natürlich noch in den richtig farbig und beschrifteten Ordnern tun.
Du musst auch Möglichkeiten lassen, das zu verbessern, dass du sagst, wir verbessern jetzt, wir schimpfen den Kunden nicht nur, sondern wir nennen ihn auch richtig noch ein Arschloch und legen dann auf, dann hast du deine Prozedur sogar noch verbessert. Solange du das dokumentierst, kriegst du Qualitätssicherheit. Wir haben ja Qualität, will ich damit sagen. Wir sollten uns mal ISO 9000-Zertifizieren.
Wir sind ein Qualitäts-Podcast. Das sind wir.
So, ich möchte gerne noch kurz was Schönes mal machen, weil das war so deprimierend jetzt hier mit Apple und so im Peak Apple und überhaupt und so.
Mach mal was Schönes.
Mach mal.
Habtet ihr das schon ein bisschen mal den Leuten auf Twitter schon mal nahe gebracht, weil du jetzt neulich auch in einer Freak Show mal so ein bisschen über den Uno gejubelt hast? Wie siehts da eigentlich aus?
Ich hab über den Uno gejubelt.
War das nicht der Uno?
Ich hab glaub ich über den Kogoro gejubelt.
Geht jetzt mal Elektromobilität.
Na ja, man kann ja den Kogoro leider nicht kaufen. Man kann ihn hier nur mieten. Ich miete den gerne, aber ich würd auch lieber einen kaufen. Aber man kann ja keinen kaufen.
Ich wollte nur sagen, ich hab das jetzt mal ein bisschen, wollte jetzt mal wissen, ob das so wirklich so ist. Und stelle fest, dass die Infrastruktur durchaus da ist. Was hast du denn jetzt? Gerade in Berlin. Also Elektromobilität. Mal, wir laden jetzt. Wir gucken jetzt mal, wo man so laden kann.
Hast du was zum laden?
Ja.
Was denn?
Ist irrelevant. Das ist für dieses, ist ein Auto. Ist jetzt kein Elektroroller oder sonst immer, das probier ich mal im Herbst aus, aber ist jetzt mal mit dem Auto mal geguckt, ob man so mal was laden kann.
Wenn es kalt ist, dann probiert er mal ein Roller aus.
Geht Lien oder hast du oder uns?
Das ist irrelevant. Ich möchte jetzt keine Autodiskussion führen.
Ich wollte eher eine Besitzdiskussion führen, aber ist egal. Move on. Du hattest etwas, was man laden kann.
Ich hab den doch immer noch, aber man kann damit jetzt so mal testen. Ich wollte jetzt mal gucken, wie das so ist, wenn man so rumgeht. Mal ein bisschen schnorren, strom schnorren geht.
Öffentliche...
Egal wie. Gucken, ob du damit klarkommst. Also ob du abprallst oder so.
Was für eine Kategorie von Auto reden wir denn? Wie viele Kilowattstunden?
90. Es gibt ja nicht so viele zur Auswahl. Mit 90. Man kann durchaus... Hier in Berlin geht es sehr gut. Du hast überall eigentlich Infrastruktur. Was ich festgestellt habe, ist, dass es sehr viel Infrastruktur noch gibt, wo man umsonst laden kann. Also... Gratis. Ja, stimmt. Gratis.
Was sind für welche?
Nur so Läden, die dir das zur Verfügung stellen.
Läden?
Ja, Läden. Ein Beispiel ist O-Beta. Kennen wir vielleicht ein paar Leute. Das ist dieser Elektro-Großhandel. Da steht zwar meistens immer ein Proligamonteur davor. Den scheust du da halt weg. Und dann steckst du dich da an. Find ich sehr gut. Oder an anderen Stellen, zum Beispiel Tank und Rast. Ist ja so dieser Großbetreiber, der bundesweit diese komischen Raststellen da betreibt, als Pächter vom Bund oder keine Ahnung wie. Weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die Gesellschaftsstruktur da ist. Die haben jetzt auch überall Ladesäulen da oder bauen die auf, aber haben die auch sehr viel. Auch mit Gleichstromladern, also mit schnellem Zeugs und so. Ist derzeit auch noch für Ome. Ja, finde ich sehr cool. Dann war ich auch mal im Außenlande, war da mit in Prag. Hab da vorher hingemailt ans Hotel, hab gesagt, gibt es bei euch Strom? Und die so, ja... Ist eigentlich kein Problem. Allerdings sind unsere Steckdosen ein bisschen gammelig, das kann, dann musst du halt draußen laden. Also bei denen in der Garage. Okay, stell die sich raus, die Außensteckdosen waren auch gammelig, musste dann drei ausprobieren. Also die dritte hat dann funktioniert.
Wenn wir von Steckdosen reden, reden wir von was?
Schoko-Steckdosen?
Nee, nee, die so Drehstrom. CE, also diese roten Dinger.
Die roten Runden.
Also normaler Drehstrom.
Ja, also du kannst, wenn du jetzt ein ordentliches Auto hast, mit einem entsprechenden Adapter-Set oder Kabel-Set, kannst du eigentlich von allem möglichen laden. Kannst halt eben aus einer Schoko-Steckdose laden. Da kommt in der Regel nicht so viel raus.
Wie viel Kilometer pro Stunde?
Da müsste man jetzt mal ausreden. Da kommen maximal 3,7 Kilowatt raus aus einer Schoko-Steckdose. Und naja, wenn du damit 90 laden willst, dann dauert das halt noch eine Weile. Aber die roten Dinger, 16, 32 Ampere, teilweise auch 63 Ampere oder sowas, kriegst du. Und was ich halt absehend von diesen technischen Themen, mit Stecker-Themen und so und so, aber was ich sehr interessant fand, ist, dass die Leute dem sehr aufgeschlossen sind. Die Tschechen sagten auch, ja, hier kommt kein Salat, kostet auch nichts. Kann man auch verstehen, weil das ist halt ein großes Hotel dort. Die haben eh zu tschechischen Preisen und Gewerbestrom, wenn die mir eine Rechnung sich hinsetzen und 10 Minuten an der Rechnung schreiben, haben sie schon mehr Verlust gemacht, als mir das jetzt zu berechnen und so. Also man wird eigentlich sehr gerne willkommen heißen damit und kriegt da auch easy peasy über mal so ein bisschen Strom. Was so ein bisschen nervig ist an dieser Stelle, muss ich sagen, ist natürlich mal wieder der politische Aspekt. Also man sieht deutlich, dass der Wille da ist, das zu machen. Also auch öffentliche und so. Es gibt so ein paar schnarchnasige Städte, wie zum Beispiel in Potsdam. In Potsdam gibt es ungefähr 2,5 Lader. Die sind zwar dann umsonst, aber an obskuren Ecken, oder dann musst du halt auf einen bezahlten Parkplatz drauf fahren, ist okay, wenn der Strom umsonst ist, aber trotzdem, der hat dann auch nicht 24 mal 7 auf oder so. In Berlin gibt es an jeder Ecke so ein Ding, aber dann gibt es welche, die haben so ein ganz krasses Tarifschema. Manche machen ja nach Zeit, wo du sagst, du kannst dich an das Ding anschließen, egal wie viel Strom du ziehst, solange du da lädst, läuft die Uhr, und die Uhr hat halt so Tarife, wie die erste Viertelstunde kostet 1,70 irgendwas, danach kostet das und das, aber zwischen 20 und 8 Uhr kostet wieder das und das, und das ist völlig behämmert. Andere sind wieder, wie gesagt, umsonst, denn die fairesten, wie ich immer noch finde, sind einfach die, wo du einfach einen Tarif zahlst, so was weiß ich, 30 Cent für die Kilowattstunde, das sind diese Wattenfall-Säulen, die hier auch überall rumstehen, wie wir es auch bei Ikea, oder auch in Parkgaragen, habe ich zum Beispiel jetzt mal geguckt, und das ist einfach interessant, wenn man jetzt das mal macht, dann interessiert man sich auch dafür, wo jetzt überall diese Dinger sind. Und gibt es also schon da in größeren Einkaufszentren oder so, gibt es immer da, wo diese Parkgaragen sind, muss man mal gucken, gibt es eine Ecke, da steht ja mal so ein Lader. Oder wie es sagt, bei Ikea auf dem Parkplatz oder so. Die machen doch Elektroautos jetzt?
Das ist ja so ein interessanter Punkt dieser ganzen Debatte, dass man immer sagt, wenn ich dann mal laden muss, dann dauert es lange. Aber dass man eigentlich viele Wege, wo man so Abstellzeiten, so temporäre hat, so der Ikea-Besuch und so weiter, Supermarkt, hier mal eine Stunde, da mal zwei Stunden, sozusagen die Chara mehr oder weniger die ganze Zeit vorgeladen hält, das ist natürlich nochmal ein ganz anderer Aspekt.
Das gibt es selbst bei Lidl oder bei Rewe. Und dann dann meistens sogar noch umsonst. Da kommen dann zwar nicht irgendwie Gigawatt raus, aber trotzdem, den Power, den du brauchst, um da hinzufahren, kriegst du locker wieder raus. Und ab diesem Dauern stellst du das Ding halt eben abends zu Hause hin, wenn du kannst. Dann steckst du ihn da an und ist das nächsten Tag auch wieder gerinselt. Was echt nervt ist diese politische Geschichte mit diesen Abrechnungsthemen. Also x Betreiber selbst in Deutschland, irgendwie Dutzende von Ladennetzen, von irgendwelchen Providern. Manche, die mit anderen rohmen, manche, die wieder nicht mit irgendwelchen rohmen. Oder ich hab dann so obscure Sachen entdeckt, wie ein Ladedingsten. Was eigentlich von New Motion betrieben wird, steht auch drauf. Halt ich meinen New Motion-Ladeschlüssel, das ist so ein Airfit-Chipchen. Halt ich dagegen und sag, ne, ich glaub ich nicht. Dann wollt ich fast viel abhauen und ich sag, jetzt probier ich noch mal einen anderen. Ich hab noch einen von Plug Surfing, glaub ich so einen gelben, dagegen gehalten. Der ging dann plötzlich. Also die Konkurrenz geht dann plötzlich an so einer Ladestation. Also das ist alles irgendwie so ein bisschen, da müsste man jetzt echt was machen. Vor allen Dingen, diese Dinger kommunizieren ja mit dem Auto. Die haben ja noch eine Datenschnittstelle mit dem Auto, über diese alle Möchenparameter übertragen. Was man eigentlich möchte, ist, dass man sagt, hier, ich kriege dir für mein Auto ein Konto ein oder ich lade mein Auto mit irgendwelchem Geld auf und das wird dann ausgetauscht oder ich zahl per Kreditkarte oder sonst was. Aber die sind gefummelt mit dem, welchen Dienst kann ich jetzt hier benutzen und welche, manche steuerst du mit Ups, manche für diesen Ladesäulen, da hast du gar keinen Airfit mehr, das machst du dann mit einer App auf dem Telefon. Und dieser Zuo, das müsste mal aufgeräumt werden. Aber abgesehen davon, meine ich, hab jetzt, keine Ahnung, drei, vier so eine Ladeschüssel und zwei Ups. Ich hab jetzt immer Sachen angeklickt, weil jetzt auch so Test mal ein bisschen sein sollte, wo ich jetzt keine monatliche Grundgebühren für habe. Das heißt, man kann sich da durchaus mal vier, fünf Accounts zusammenklicken. Aber das funktioniert eigentlich schon ganz gut. Also wir kommen dahin. Das heißt, wenn jetzt Tesla mal anfängt, da irgendwie Model 3 auszuliefern, dann lass mal loslegen.
Ja, wenn sie mal in den Puschen kommen. Macht bisher den Eindruck, aber wird sich dann erst noch mal zeigen. Aber es sollten mal ein paar andere mal.
Im Juli ist Produktionsstart und Reveal-Event.
Hat das Ding eine Anhängerkupplung?
Angeblich wird es wohl auch eine Anhängerkupplung als...
Das Model 3? Also jetzt können sie in Norwegen wieder nicht verkaufen.
Hab ich irgendwo gelesen. Es kann aber sein, dass die ersten, also die wollen ja den Zoo an Varianten am Anfang sehr sehr niedrig halten. Und sehr wahrscheinlich werden die ersten Model 3s auch keine Anhängerkupplung haben. Die kriegen ja auch kein All-Wheel-Drive und die kriegen wahrscheinlich auch kein Schiebefenster.
Und ob du da deinen Wohnwagen rangehangen bekommst?
Naja, also...
Wenn du irgendwo rangehangen bekommst, dann da, ja.
Also ich kann einen dranhängen.
Wie schnell ist deine Batterie denn alle?
1250 Kilo Zuglast. Geht's du? Aber du hast einen Anhänger? Wir reden gerade über Anhänger.
Wie schwer ist der?
Maximal zulässig 1500.
Geht.
Ja, okay, ich komm dann vorbei.
Dann leidet die Range halt ein bisschen drunter, aber ranhängen kannst du den.
Gibt ja diesen bekloppten Norweger, der auf YouTube immer alle möglichen Sachen ausprobiert. Diese ganzen macht das mal nicht probierter aus. Also wenn zum Beispiel er fährt mit dem Tesla Model X rum und steht halt auch immer drin, du sollst das Ding jetzt nicht auf Null runterfahren. Wär halt blöd.
Da hab ich aber schon diverse Videos von diversen Leuten gesehen.
Aber der probiert diese ganzen Dinge aus. Neulich hat er auch geschrieben, hat er mal getwittert, er will jetzt sein nächstes Projekt, was er mal ausprobieren will, er will jetzt mal gucken, ob er mit seinem Model X und der Anhängerkupplung ein A380 gezogen kriegt. Hab ich ihm gleich zurückgeschrieben, es gibt auch bessere Methoden, dir die Anhängerkupplung aus dem Arsch zu ziehen, aber mach mal. Keine Ahnung, würde er sich irgendwo jemanden suchen, wo so ein Ding landet und so, und dann mal testen, er möchte gerne mal ein A380 ziehen mit seinem Model X.
Aber da habt ihr neulich bei dieser Sendung, also nicht Sendung mit der Maus, sondern fragt doch mal die Maus, so heißt die Sendung irgendwie von einem halben Jahr, haben irgendwelche Ruderer, das war keine A380, sondern A320 oder so, haben den gezogen und haben ihn irgendwie schneller gezogen, als die dazugehörige Zugmaschine. Also mit einparken und allem drum und dran, deswegen hatten die einen Vorteil. Aber die haben irgendwie, diese Rudermannschaft hat da dieses Flugzeug gezogen.
Vielleicht sind die auch einfach gut gelagert, diese Flugzeuge, wer weiß.
Ja, also ich kann mir das gut vorstellen, dass man ein Flugzeug gezogen kriegt.
Aber ich dachte ja, ein A380 bin schon ein paar Mal mit so einem Monster geflogen, das ist schon noch echt ein Drumm.
Jaja, natürlich.
Aber die Masse ist ja nicht das Problem, sondern die Reibungsenergie der Reifen. Wenn du dich an so einen Güterwaggon anlehnst, dann musst du nur warten. Das Ding bewegt sich irgendwann, irgendwann schreckt er an zu rollen.
Ja, selbst größere Lokomotiven.
Du kannst den so mit der Hand schieben, aber dauert halt. Aber das ist halt gut gelagert, die Scheiße.
Das meint der Charan aus dem Club, hier bei seinem Siemens Gas-Turbinenwerk in Berlin, dass sie da so eine hydraulischen Tische haben, um die Turbinen da umherzufahren, wo dann so ein relativ geringer Druck unter diese Tische gepustet wird. Dann schweben die da über den Fabrikboden mit diesen Gas-Turbinen. Und da ist es dann wohl auch so, da ist halt die Reimung quasi null. Da kannst du dich dann auch gegen so eine Gas-Turbine lehnen, für so ein Kraftwerk, die dann so durch die Halle wabert. Da gibt es ja jedes Jahr irgendwie so einen Tag der offenen Tür. Und irgendwie haben wir es bisher immer verpasst, so einen Nordausflug ins Gas-Turbinen-Werk von Siemens in Berlin zu schaffen. Das müssen wir mal machen.
Also zusammenfassend kann man machen. Jetzt bin natürlich spannend, wie wenn es langsam mal voll wird. Neulich hatte ich mal eine Situation, da stand ich auch an einem Lader. Das war einer von diesen Tank- und Rastladern. Und da rotteten sich dann glatt noch zwei Teslas mit hinzu. Und dann ist man ja auch nett. Dann sagt man, was hast du für ein Kennzeichen? Oder hast du es noch weit heute Abend? Dann mach du mal.
Man ist ja noch unter sich, da ist man ja noch nett zueinander. Das ist bei den Pionierzeiten immer so, ne?
Mal sehen, wie das wird, wenn jetzt alle 400 Opel Amperas mal auf den Markt kommen.
Der ist doch jetzt alle der Papst eingesammelt.
Zählst du die aus Österreich und Italien mit, oder was?
Ich glaube, das ist die Gesamtproduktion, die Opel je geplant hat davon, oder so, weiß ich nicht. Aber es gibt schon noch obskure Dinge dabei.
Werden die überhaupt in Deutschland produziert? Ich meine, das ist doch dieser Chevy Bolt, den sie in Amiland auch nur in den Stückzahlen produzieren, die sie müssen, damit sie ihre Steuerermäßigung bekommen. Das ist ganz offensichtlich, dass die Händler, die immer nur minutenweise haben, bis sie dann jemand weggekauft hat. Und die kriegen immer nur ein paar.
Aber wir werden das noch häufiger sehen, dieses Thema, das wird noch spannend.
So, aber jetzt ziehen wir die Feder runter.
Leiten wir das Ende ein.
Eine kurze 200.
Genau, eine kurze 200. Das war's.
Festlich, wie erwartet.
Rumgefliegt, genau.
Wo ist der Champagner, Tim?
Ja, kommt alles.
Du hast Fanta, ich bitte dich.
Schampfanta?
Schampfanta, genau.
Ich wünsche dir alles Gute da draußen.
Viel Spaß, bleib uns treu.
In zwei Wochen sind wir wieder da.
Tschüssi!